Természetben többféle formában fordulnak
elő a cukrok. Ennek a a lehető
legbázikusabb, legegyszerűbb formájaú
monoszaharritok, amelyek egyetlen egy
cukormolekulából állnak. Hát az ecet úgy
általában nagyon egészséges, mert egy
probiotikus, tehát amennyiben fermentált
ecetről van szó,
az egy probiotikus készítmény. A vitamin
és a zásványianyagtartalommal is vannak
egy picit ilyen félreértések vagy
mitoszok. Tehát, hogy például a
C-vitamint tartalma az almaliének, tehát
már ahogy a gyümölcsöt leszedjük a
fáról, a C-vitamintartalom esik, ahogy
levegővel érintkezik a C-vitamin,
oxidálódik, tehát hogy tönkremegy.
Gyümölcslével is ez a helyzet, hogy
megnövekedik a felület, amin eloszlik,
az a C-vitamin, tehát sokkal gyorsabban
oxidálódik. Tehát abba az almadébe már
sok C-vitamin nincsen.
>> Üdvözlök mindenkit a műsorunkban. A mai
napi vendégünk, Dr. Lőrinci Kincső már
volt nemréga a Csak a Baj podcast
vendége, úgyhogy nem mutatom be külön.
Viszont ha nem láttátok még azt az
epizódot, mindenképpen ajánlom, ugyanis
az egy nagyon jó alapozása volt a a
annak a témának, amiről ma fogunk
beszélgetni, de mindenesetre Kincse
üdvözöllek a Navigátor podcastben.
>> Hát én én én remélem, hogy senkinek nem
fogok csalódást okozni. Örülök, hogy
ismét itt lehetek és hogy
beszélgethetünk. Már itt veled még most
találkozok először te, hogy egy újabb
podcastbe meg lettem hívva. Számomra egy
hatalmas megtiszteltetés.
>> Nekem is az, hogy eljöttél, és úgy
képzeld el, hogy amikor megfogalmazódott
bennem, hogy szeretnék valakivel leülni,
beszélgetni, tehát az történt, hogy
körülbelül egy olyan fél éve a kezembe
került egy könyv, a Jessie Anchespnak a
a glukóz forradalma. Pontosabban nem is
a kezembe került, hanem a feleségem a
kezembe adta. Egy olyan borítója van
amúgy a hallgatók kedvére elmondom, amit
biztos sem olvastam volna el magamtól.
Tehát egy olyan olyan tipikus feminin
könyv, amit amit amit én nem néztem
volna soha a könyve könyves polcon ki
magamnak, de elolvasta a feleségem és
azt mondta, hogy erről tudnom kell
olvassam én is. Főleg azért, mert én
évekkel ezelőtt elkezdtem a ketó
étrendet azért, hogy egy akkor fogyás ér
főként, de időközben rájöttem, hogy így
nagyon jót tesz a testemnek a ketó,
tehát kevesebb alvásra van szükségem,
energikusabb vagyok,
gyakorlatilag minden egyes pozitív
előrejelzett hatása érvényes volt rám
is. Viszont az a baj a ketóval az én
életemben, hogy hogy nagyon nehezen
tudom megtartani a ketogéntrendet.
nagyon
sok fegyelem kell hozzá, és gyakran
gyakran csaltam, és egy idő után már azt
vettem észre, hogy többször csalok, mint
mint nem csalok, és akkor utána
próbálkoztam a carnivorral, és ezekről
mind majd kérlek
a majd jelezd vissza ezzel kapcsolatban,
hogy majd mutassuk be. De a lényeg az,
hogy ezek mind olyan étrendek voltak,
amiket nem tudtam tartani, őszintén
szólva.
Úgyhogy amikor a kezembe került ez a
könyv és egy mélyebb szinten kezdtem
belelátni abba, hogy a testünkben mit
okoz például a glükóz és a
vércukorszínek a szerepe mi, akkor akkor
nagyon fellelkesedtem, hiszen olyan
pofon egyszerű tanácsokat adott Jessie,
amiket én is ki tudtam próbálni
időközben, és azt láttam, hogy nálam
működnek, egytől egyig működik
mindegyik. És ami még számomra pozitív
volt, hogy Jessie úgy indította ezt az
egész könyvet, hogy volt egy balesete,
és a baleset következményeként olyan
érzése volt, mintogyha ha a teste és a
belső érzete úgymond, tehát mintogyha
nem érezné a testét pontosan, mintogyha
nem lenne összeköttetés. És mivel ő egy
egy biológus és egy kutató, ezért
gondolom, hogy hogy korábban volt
hozzáférése egy ilyen CGM-hez, ezér a
continuous glucóz monitor, egy ilyen
folyamatos vércokorszín mérőhöz, ami egy
ilyen tapasz, mi is bemutatjuk
hamarosan, egy ilyen tapasz, amit hogyha
felrakunk, akkor körülbelül olyan 10-14
napig a mobiltelefonunkon látjuk a a
vércukorszintünket, az aktuális
vércukorszintünket. És akkor Jessie
elkezdett kísérletezni ezzel a
vércukorszintel, hogy pontosabban azt
látta, hogy hogy vagyis az volt a terve,
hogy hogyan lehetne alacsonyan tartani a
vércukorszintet. Úgyhogy és ebből
született egy könyv, bemutatott 10 ilyen
trükköt úgymond, de az tetszett ezekbe a
trükkökbe, hogy nagyon egyszerűek,
nagyon megközelíthetőek.
viszont arra gondoltam, hogy hívnék egy
szakembert, aki aki ezekben tudna nekem
segíteni eligazodni, mert ami túl
egyszerű, azért gyanús. Úgyhogy arra és
ahogy feltettem így a az ismerőseim
között a kérdést, hogy vajag kivel
tudnék leülni, nagyon sok ismerősöm
pont téged javasolt, és nagyon örvöndek,
hogy le tudunk ülni most egyet
beszélgetni. Az a terem, hogy egy kicsit
járjuk körbe, vezessük be ezt a témát.
Az epizódnak is ez lesz amúgy a címe,
hogy a glüózforradalom, mint a könyvnek
a címe, de szeretném végigjárni
egyrészt, hogy mi is a glükóz pontosan,
és miért miért lehet ez egy ilyen, tehát
miért lehet a címe ennek a könyvnek
glükózforradalom? De kezdjük egyszer is
a glükózzal, hogy mi is a glükóz?
>> Tehát magyarosítva a nevét szőlőcukor,
de egy monozzaharit, tehát a
természetben többféle formában fordulnak
elő a cukrok.
Ennek a lehető legbázikusabb,
legegyszerűbb formája monozaharritok,
amelyek egyetlen egy cukormolekulából
állnak. Az emberi test számára nagyjából
négy ilyen monozaharid létezik, amivel
tud tud ismit kezdeni a testünk.
Legfontosabb a glükóz. Ez az, ami emeri
a vércukorszinteket, és amelyeket
testünk jóéhány sejtje előszeretettel
használ, mint energiaforrás.
Ezenkívül létezik a fruktóz. Ennek a
magyar neve a gyümölcscukor. Nagyon
gyakran együtt fordul elő a glószal,
elsősorban a gyümölcsökben.
Van a galaktóz, ami a tejcukornak, a
laktóznak az egyik komponense.
Ezt általában tehát felveszi a testünk,
de direkt mód a mágyba kerül, és azonnal
glükóz lesz belőle. Tehát így mint
galaktóz szervezetünkben nem sok szerep
jut neki.
És van a mannóz, ilyen babfélékben
fordul elő, gombafélékben, nagyon kis
mennyiségben tudja a szervezetünk
használni.
Ezekből az egyszerű cukrokból, hogyha
ezek kombinálódnak, bonyolultabb cukrok
is keletkeznek, és általában az
élelmiszerekbe és a természetbe így
szoktak előfordulni. Tehát hogyha
például két glukózmolekula találkozik,
akkor ebből lesz a malátacukor.
És ennek a malátacukornak van tehát egy
másik molekulaszerkezete treóz lesz
belőle, de ugyanaz a két glukózmolekula
adja a szerkezetet, csak kicsit másképp
kötődnek egymáshoz ezek ezek a
molekulák. Ha egy glukóz és egy fruktóz
találkozik, abból lesz a szaharóz.
Ez adja az a a kristálycukrot, illetve a
mézet.
Ha pedig egy glukóz és a galaktóz
találkozik, akkor ebből lesz a tejcukor,
vagyis a laktóz. És aztán vannak ennél
bonyolultabb szerkezetek is, tehát 310
cukormolekulát tartalmaznak az oliko
zaharidok. És akkor vannak a
polizzaharidok, ahol már 10 fölötti
cukormolekulák találhatók meg, ezek a
keményítők.
Tehát a keményítőnek is több típusa van.
Öhet ez a keményítő, sima keményítő,
ahol alfakötések
találhatók a cukormolekulák között, a
glükózmolekulák között. Tehát a
keményítőt elsősorban a glükóz alkotja.
Van a rezisztens keményítő, ahol amit
ami megtalálható így a természetben, de
az ételekben bizonyos ilyen
konyhatechnikai eszközökkel is el lehet
érni, hogy a a normálemyítő rezisztensé
alakuljon. Azt kell tudni, hogy nem
véletlen rezisztens a neve. Tehát, hogy
mi az emésztően enzimeink nem igazán
tudnak hozzáférni, és ezért nem tudjuk
emészteni őket. És akkor vannak a a
rostok, mint például a cellulóz. Egész
egyszerűen mi nem rendelkezünk olyan
enzimekkel, hogy a cellulózt lebontsuk.
Általában ezt baktériumok szokták
végezni még az állatvilágban is. Tehát
például a a az ilyen kérődző emlősök,
tehát a tehén, jó kecske,
ezeknek tehát egyrészt azt kell tudni,
hogy sokkal hosszabb érendszerük van,
mint nekünk. Tehát például a a tehéni
ugye átlagosan a 40-60 m, az emberi 68
és hogy ott rengetegféle baktérium él,
ami rendelkezik ezekkel a az emésztő
enzimekkel,
de hogy ez nagyon energiaigényes
folyamat a rostóból energiát csinálni,
és nem feltétlen kifizetődő, ezért
esznek ők egész nap, tehát legelnek
reggeltől estig. Nálunk az embereknél
evolúciós szempontból ez nem volt
előnyös, és ezért ezt úgy mondják, hogy
rövid, bél, nagy agy elmélet, tehát hogy
mivel az agyunk is nagyon
energiaigényes, ezért mi átálltunk a a
tehát az ilyen nagy energiahorttozókra,
a zsírokra és a glükózra, és nem
fordított a természet akkora figyelmet a
a rostoknak a bontására, merthogy hogy
túlságosan sok energiát elvont volna az
az agytevékenys éktől, s akkor inkább az
agyunkat fejlesztette a természet, nem a
bérlrendszerünket.
>> A következő dolog, ami ami emlékszem,
amikor a könyben megértettem, akkor
akkor felgyúlt egy lámpa, és nagyon
kíváncsi vagyok, hogy ezzel kapcsolatban
mi lesz majd így a a kommented, vagyis a
a visszajelzésed.
Mégpedig az, hogy a glukóz mekkora.
A megkérdeztem a chat GPT-t, és azt
mondta, hogy úgy képzeljem el, mintogyha
egy futballpályának a méretéhez képest a
focilabdának a mérete. Tehát a sejt maga
a futballpálya, és a glükóz maga egy
csak egy focilabda méretű. Tehát, hogy
kicsi apró ahhoz képest. Én én sehogy
sem képzeltem el őszintén. Szóval de ez
így felgyújtott bennem egy lámpát, mert
Jessie arról ír, hogy amikor
megemésztünk valamit, aminek lükóz
tartalma van, akkor szét árad mindenhova
a testünkbe. Körülbelül percek alatt, 15
perc alatt körülbelül bárhol már mérhető
lesz. Ezért van az, hogy az ujjunkon is
tudjuk mérni a vércukorszintünket.
És így teljesen másképp képzeltem el
őszintén szólva addig a a glukózt. És és
Jessie arról beszélt, hogy a magas
vércukorszint
az mennyi minden káros.
Mennyi minden
negatív hatása van a testünkben. Például
az egyik dolgot, amit én is én én is
folyamatosan észrevettem, hogyha
felugrik a vércukor, szinten valamit
megeszek, ami ami magas
szénhidráttartalmú,
és utána pedig v visszaesik a
vércukorszintem, és ezt a dinamikát
kérlek, akkor majd bontsd ki, hogy miért
történik. akkor azt mondta, hogy
olyankor éhség, érzett, szédülés,
álmosság, fáradtság, tehát és és ez a
folyamatos vércukorszinti ingadozás ezt
eredményezi. Úgyhogy ezért gondolta
Jessie, hogy hogy az optimális az,
amikor amikor nem nincsenek túl nagy
kiugrások a vércukorszintünkben.
Egy kicsit beszélnél akkor erről, hogy
egyrészt a glükóz az mire is jó a
testünkben? Ez az első kérdésem. És a
másik az, hogy a túl sok glükóz pedig
miért nem jó a testünkben?
Hát vissza kell menjünk az ősemberhez,
hogy mind a két kérdésre válaszolni
tudjak. Tehát azt kell tudni, hogy
amikor mi az egyed fejlődés során így
kialakultunk, mint ember, elkülönültünk,
mint faj,
tehát hogy ilyen vadászógyűjtögető
életmódot folytattunk, és ez az életmód,
ez azt jelentette, hogy elsősorban
sísírokat, fehérjét fogyasztottunk,
rostot,
nagyon kevés szénhidrátot, tehát a
szénhidrát szezonális volt, és ehhez
alkalmazkodott a testünk.
Ez azt jelenti, hogy tehát, hogy nem
voltak jók a nagycukoringadozások, mert
ez destabilizálta egy kicsikét az agy és
az izomműködést, és hogyha például
valami veszélyhelyzet volt, akkor egy
ilyen fluktuáló, tehát hogy hullámzó
vércukorszint, az egyrészt a az agynak a
kritikus döntéshozó képességét nagyon
befolyásolta volna. Tehát például lehet,
hogy hogy nem a jó menekülő utat
választjuk, hogyha jön a kartfogó
tigris, illetve az izmoknak a teherbíró
képességét csökkentette volna, tehát
hogy inkább áldozatául estünk volna egy
nagyadozónak.
Kettő, hogy tehát egész egyszerűen
voltak éhezéses időszakok, amihez megint
csak alkalmazkodni kellett. Tehát az
étel nem volt olyan egyértelmű, mint
most, hogy bemegyünk a a nagy
üzletláncokba, és akkor ott
megvesároljuk, ami éppen tetszik nekünk
a polcról. Ö tehát, hogy voltak
időszakok, amikor azt a mamutot éppen
levadászta az ember, az az egy több
napos vagy hetes tevékenység volt, és
azalatt nagyon gyakran éheztek, vagy mit
tudom én, minimális
elmiszerrel kellett kibírni azt a
periódust. És hogy ehhez a szervezet
alkalmazkodott úgy, hogy leszorította az
inzulin szinteket, hogy beinduljon a
zsíréget és a ketózis.
Inzul, tehát magas inzulinszintek
mellett egész egyszerűen a zsírégetés
nem jöhet létre. Tehát hiába, hogy van
elraktározott zsír a bőrünk alatt, nem
tudunk hozzáférni, és hogyha túlságosan
magasak a cukors szintek, az magas
inzulinválaszt vált ki, és akkor egész
egyszerűen a a két, tehát a a két ilyen
cukorbevitel közti időszakban nem férünk
hozzá a zsírokhoz. Ö na most ö az a
helyzet, hogy ez a ez a cukorbőség,
amivel mi most szembesülünk,
az nem volt mindig így. Tehát, hogy ez
nagyjából egy olyan 200 éves jelenség,
de hogy hogy mi egy kicsit nagyon
idealizáljuk a történelmet, de hogy m mi
nem azt az életet éljük, amit az ük ők a
páink. Tehát, hogy nekik se volt olyan
egyértelmű, hogy minden nap szénhidrátot
tudnak enni és kenyeret és tehát ilyen
ilyen nagyon könnyen hozzáférhető
cukrokat. Tehát hogy ott is azért
megvolt, hogy hogy akkor amikor a
gyümölcs érett, akkor jutottak hozzá
nagyobb szénhidrát forráshoz. voltak
gabonák, de azok a gabonák sokkal
rostosabbak voltak, sokkal durvábban
tudták akkor megőrülni őket, mert az
ilyen malomtechnikai dolgok nem voltak
annyira fejlettek, mint manapság. Tehát,
hogy az sem volt egy olyan nagy mértékű
cukorbevitel. Most kérdezted, hogy mi a
szerepe a glóznak a a testünkben? Tehát,
hogy kell a glükóz, mert vannak olyan
sejtek, amik csak és kizárólag ezt
tudják használni, mint energia. Tehát
minden sejtnek az életben maradáshoz, a
működésre, az energiára van szüksége. És
ezt az energiát
cukrokból, ha van rá lehetőség és
zsírokból nyerik. Azt kell tudni, hogy a
sejtek általában, tehát úgy általában,
ha csak lehetőségük van rá, preferálják
a cukrot, mert metabolikus szempontból
sokkal könnyebb
elbontani a cukrot és energiát csinálni
belőle, annak ellenére, hogy egy cukor,
tehát
molekula az csak 4 kkalóriát szolgáltat
ellen, tehát szemben a a zsírokkal, ami
9 kkalóriát ad, tehát hogy előnyösebb
volna a zsírégetés, de sokkal nagyobb
energiaráfordítást igényel a szervezet
részéről.
Mik azok a sejtek, amik csak cukrot
tudnak, tehát glükózt ki kell
hangsúlyozom, hogy a cukrok közül a
glükózt tudják használni.
Májsejtek. Tehát a májsejtek azok azok
nagyon sok mindent átalakítanak, tehát
egyik vegyületet a másikba, de mint
energiaforrás a glükózt használják,
viszont ők azt meg is tudják csinálni,
tehát hogy fehérjékből, illetve bizonyos
zsírsavakból képesek
glükózszintetizálni. Tehát, hogy ők el
vannak látva. ezen kívül a retinában a
tehát a fotóreceptorok, tehát azok a
sejtek, amik a napfényt felfogják,
azok szintén glükózt használnak, mert a
fény az tehát a fotonok azok ilyen
reaktív oxigéngyépződést váltanak ki
ezekben a ezekben a sejtekben, ami egy
nagyon gyulladásos folyamat, tehát
károsítani a sejteket és a a glükóz
segít
azoknak a folyamatoknak a
fenntartásában, ami ezt minimalizálja.
Ezenkívül a vesében bizonyos sejtek, az
idegrendszerben és a perifériás idegek
szintjén, illetve a bélfalssejtek. És
miért hangsúlyoztam ki ezeket a
szöveteket? úgy van jelentősége, mert
kérdezted, hogy mi a baj a sok cukorral,
és ide akarok visszakanyarodni, hogy
pont azért, mivel ezek a sejtek a
felsorolásból kimaradt a vörös vértest,
ők is csak cukrok tudnak használni, de
hogy a a az említett sejtek az, hogy
nincsenek inzulin receptoraik, tehát
inzulin nélkül is képesek felvenni a
cukrot, és ez nagyon fontos evolúciós
szempontból, tehát hogy nagyon nagy
energiaigényű sejtek és csak cukrot
tudnak használni. Ezért ha alacsony a
cukorbevite, tehát éhezés van, vagy a
környezetben
nincsen, tehát nincs cukor, csak zsír
vagy fehérje van, akkor is kell cukrot
kapjanak, és ezért nem kell az inzulin
hozzájuk, hogy az a kevés cukor is, ami
a szervezetben megtalálható, vagy
termelődik, az egyből hozzájuk
irányuljon.
Csak ezzel az a probléma, hogy mivel nem
ér, tehát nem kell az inzulin hozzájuk,
ezért nincs is ami leszabályozza, hogy
mennyi cukrot vesznek fel. Ha túlságosan
magas a vércukors szint, akkor ezek a
sejtek egész egyszerűen
megfuladnak a cukortól, és tehát nem
tudják leszobályozni, hogy mennyi kerül
be beléjük, mennyit vesznek fel,
rengeteget felvesznek, és ezzel a
cukorral nem tudnak mit csinálni, és
akkor van bennük egy ilyen poliolciklus,
ez egy kémiai reakció, amikor ők
védekezésképpen
ezt a cukrot a glükózátalakítják
fruktózzá.
Azt kell tudni, hogy ez egy átmeneti
megoldás, csak a sejtszám pontjából
nagyon-nagyon előnytelen és
káros.
Nem tudnak megszabadulni a fruktóztól.
Tehát mielő a fruktóz kialakult, nincsen
enzimrendszerük, hogy hogy kilökjék
magukból, az ott marad. És szépen lassan
elkezd lebomlani
és ilyen, úgy mondják, intermedierek
képződnek belőle. Tehát ilyen ilyen
köztes termékek, amik nagyon reaktívak
és egy ilyen glikációs folyamatot
okoznak.
A glikáció az fehérjekárosodással járó
reakció. Három dolog kell hozzá.
Valamilyen cukormolekula, redukáló
cukor, ez glükóz, fruktóz vagy galaktóz.
Meleg és fehérje. És hogy hogy képzeljük
el ezt a folyamatot? Tehát ez a glikáció
történik akkor, amikor például hevítjük
a cukrot 160 fokon.
karamellizálódik, tehát megbarnul,
megég. Ugyanez a folyamat zajlik a
amikor a húst karamellizáljuk az olajban
vagy a zsiradékban. Tehát hogy úgy
megkapatjuk a szélét, megbarnul a széle,
azért mert a húsban is van cukor,
glikogén formájában van fehérje, és ott
a meleg közeg, ami ezt a glikációt
elősegíti. Minél melegebb van, annál
gyorsabban jön létre ez a reakció. De a
testhőmérséklet az állandó 36-37 fok
elég, hogy hogy létrejöjjön ez a
folyamat. Ha egy fehérje károsodik,
akkor ezt már visszacsinálni nem lehet.
Tehát, hogy ez ez egy maradandó dolog.
És egész egyszerűen csak úgy lehet
kijavítani, hogyha az a szövet
lecserélődik.
A a szöveteknek a a lecserélődése ez
minden szövetnél más időt vesz igénybe.
Tehát a bőr esetében ez körülbelül egy
olyan hónap, a vese esetében hat hónap
vagy egy év, az izmok, ízületek
szempontjából akár hét év is, de az agy
és a retina esetében ez
visszafordíthatatlan, tehát permanens.
Ö, és például cukorbetegeknél nem
véletlen, hogy a leggyakrabban érintett
szervek az a retina, a perifériás
idegek, illetve a vese, mert ott pont ez
a glikációs folyamat zajlik, tehát hogy
nagyjából visszafordíthatatlan
károsodások keletkeznek. És az Alzheimer
kort is ezért hívják hármas típusú
cukorbetegségnek,
merthogy ott is
tehát olyan plakok képződnek, aminek a
az alapja tehát ezek az amiloid plakok,
aminek az alapja aglikációs folyamat.
>> Ez ez eszméletlen, hogy működik az este
le lenyűgözőt. De azt most konkrétan
hogy képzeljem el? Ott van egy így
gyomorra megkívánunk egy csokis
palacsintát, és megeszünk belőle hatot
és a vércukorszintünk az egekbe száll.
És ilyenkor már ez elegendő ahhoz, hogy
egy kis mértékben kezdje a fehérjéket, a
fehérjékkel együtt ezt a
karamellizálódós folyamatot, amit
leírtál.
>> Nem, ha ésszerű mennyiségben viszünk be
glükózt, akkor nem feltétlen keletkezik
glikáció.
Ö, tehát a szervezetünk, tehát főleg
ezek a sejtek, amiket az előbb
említettem, inzulin nélkül is képesek
felvenni a cukrot, akkor van baj, hogyha
a szuprafiziológiás mennyiségben
juttatjuk be a glükózt a szervezetbe.
Egész egyszerűen akkor a szervezet egy
ilyen védekező
módban.
>> Ez mit jelent ez a szuprafiziológiás?
>> Szuprafiziológiás. Tehát a fiziológiás
az azt jelenti, hogy élettani
szempontból megfelelő
tehát akár szintű meg koncentrációjú. A
szuprafiziológiás az pedig a testnek a
normális elbírható, tehát test által
normálisan elbírható mennyiséget
meghaladó szinteket jelenti.
>> Tehát hogyha most tegyük fel hat
palacsintát megeszek, az az még nem
szuprafiziológiás
eset.
>> Hát
e itt is egyére válogatja a dolgot, de
az már elvileg kiváltja ezt a
folyamatot. De azt kell tudni, hogy
például egy jól edzett embernél, aki
fejlett izomzattal rendelkezik és
aktívan sportol, ott általában az izom
nagyon nagy részét felveszi a cukornak.
Még inzulin se kell hozzá, mert vannak
ilyen glutné receptorok rajtuk, amik
tehát, hogy amik szinte, mint a szivacs,
elszívják a cukrot a vérből. viszont egy
szedenter inaktív ember esetében, aki
inzulinrezisztens és idős,
azoknál sajnos a hat palacsinta az már
komoly problémát jelent.
>> Tehát amikor idősödik az ember, akkor
ezek egymásra teődnek ezek a ezek a
veszélyek, és mondjuk egy 20 éves
valaki, akinek a teste egészséges, ez
nem fogja annyira megérezni. Tehát régen
a kettes típusú cukorbetegséget, amiről
itt most főleg beszélünk, azt az idősebb
embereknek a betegségének, tehát így
tartották számon. Még az egyes típusú a
gyerekek betegsége volt. Ma már ez nem
ilyen egyértelmű. Miért volt az idősek
betegsége? Azért, mert idősebb korban
általában csökken a vázizomzat.
És ugye a vázmok a legnagyobb
cukorfelhasználók.
Ö manapság viszont sajnos már a 20 éves
korosztálynál is nagyon alacsony
izomzattal találkozunk. Tehát én én
diétás szaktanácsadással,
fogyókurakészítéssel is foglalkozom, és
ott testzétel méréssel szoktuk kezdeni.
Tehát az a bas lány, az első
mérés ahhoz hasonlítjuk a diéta sikerét.
És nagyon rosszul állnak. Tehát a
legtöbb ember nagyon rosszul áll az
izomzattal, de már a gyerekek is. Tehát,
hogy nem normális, hogy egy
10 éves gyermek az összizomzatban 30%
alatt van. Tehát a 30% az a kritikus
izomtömeg. Azalatt nagyon nehéz fogyni
már, vagy tehát úgy általában megtartani
a testsúlykontrollt, a
vércukorszinteket, és nagyon sokan
ezalatt a határ alatt vannak.
Visszatérve most ugye a vércukorszintre,
a számomra az volt még egy ilyen nagy
felismerés, hogy amikor magas lesz a
vércukorszintem, utána egy nagy esés
következik
amiatt, mert inzulint termel a testem és
amikor nagyon leesik, akkor történik egy
pár dolog, amit én is saját magamon
tapasztaltam. Az egyik a sóvárgás. egy
torkos személy vagyok és sajnos
és olyankor amikor sóvárgok akkor valami
szénhidrát után sóvárgok mert valami
valami olyan ami ami gyorsan felviszi
megint a vércukorszintemet és amikor egy
stresszes napom van gyakran azon kapom
magam hogy a kezem hamarabb megy mint a
működik mint az agyam tehát hogy például
beszélek telefonon kinyitom a hűtőt már
ott a számba valami és nagyon gyorsan
nagyon sok kalóriát be tudok vinni így,
hogy nem is figyelek oda és akkor megint
felmegy a vércukorszintem és ha erről
nem tudok akkor Akkor gyakorlatilag
egész nap egy ilyen
les fel, le és fel, le és fel, és ha ha
tegyük fel este, éhezem meg, akkor akkor
és akkor eszek, akkor az alvásomra is
kihad másnap reggel már elebefáradt,
erről beszéltettek Józsa Levivel is.
Úgyhogy ezt én felismertem magamban, ezt
a ezt a folyamatot, és a kettó diéta
gyakorlatilag ebben segített egy jó pár
hónapon keresztül ez a ez a
vircukorszint kiugrás,
ez ez megszűnt, és egy hihetetlen érzés
volt, amikor rájöttem arra, hogy három
hét után nem sóvárgom az étel után. És
egy és ezel a sóvárgás az egy dolog, de
ezzel együtt jár a hangulatingadozás,
depresszív tünetek. Én nem tapasztaltam
depressziót amúgy. Viszont viszont
nagyon sok minden sok helyről hallottam,
hogy hogy a a depresszív tünetek is
megszűntek embereknél. Rengeteg tünet
van, ami ilyen szempontból ennek
tulajdonítható be, hogy hogy kiugrik a
vércukorszínt. Esetleg tudnál erről egy
kicsit beszélni, hogy milyen más
mellékhatása lett így a vércukorszín
kihingásoknak? Esetleg magadon
tapasztalt tapasztaltál-e valamit?
Én mivel nagyon alacsony széhindrát
tartalom diétát folytatok, ezt annyira
nem vettem észre, de
most nem tudok ketózni, majd később
kifejtem, hogy miért, de volt idő,
amikor én is hát ilyen ilyen extrémebb
formában
diétáztam, tehát hogy nagyon nagyon
nagyon alacsony szénhidráttartalmú
diétát folytattam.
Az átállás,
tehát a ketogén diétában van egy pár
napos periódus, amit úgy hívnak, hogy
ketoflu, ahol az ember azért megszenvedi
a cukorégetésről, a zsítégetésre való
nem, ezt egyénel válogatja, hogy kinél
men mekkora időszak, ha valaki
>> tehát hogy az inzulinrezisztens vagy
cukorbeteg embereknél annyira
cukorentált a szervezet, hogy ott ez az
időszak sokkal intenzívebb és hosszabb
ideig tart.
Nagyon nehezen akarják a sejtek újra
tanulni azt, hogy hogyan is kell
lipolizálni, tehát zsírtégetni.
A fiatalabb, izmosabb embernél, aki
ráadásul tornászik is, ezt fel lehet
gyorsítani. Tehát nekem úgy általában
egy-két nap volt az átmenet. minél
gyakrabban ö csinálja meg a valaki ezt a
ketóba való átmenetet, annál ö tehát
annál jobban emlékszik a szervezet és
annál flexibilisebb lesz, tehát annál
jobban lerövidül ez az időszak. De hogy
én is ettől függetlenül mindig
megéreztem, ha egy naperejéig is. Ez
általában, ahogy te mondtad,
levertséggel járt izomfájdalmakkal. Nem
véletlen ketuflu a a neve, mert hogy
tényleg olyan, mintogyha az ember
elkapott volna egy jó rendes influenzát,
tehát fejfájás,
ilyen iritáltság, aluszékonyság,
ilyen hullámzó étvágyét étkezési
rohamok, gyengeségérzet, levertség,
elsősorban. Igen, a depresszió
fokozódhat, tehát a ketózisban való
átmenetnél
fokozódik a depresszió. És volt is nekem
ilyen betegem, aki akit figyelmeztettem
is, hogy valószínű a diéta az meg fogja
bolygatni egy kicsikét a lelki
állapotát, tehát hogy súlyos
depresszióba szenvedett és ezért
szeretett volna diétázni.
Ilyen esetekben mindig le kell állni a
diétával, utána meg lehet próbálkozni,
vagy csak részleteiben
egy-két dolgot beültetni a rutinba a
diétából, de nagyon kell vigyázni az
ilyen embereknél, mert
destabilizálóhatja a a lelki állapotot.
Ahogy te is mondtad, a cukoringadozás az
igen. Tehát miért az agyunk folyamatos
cukor utánpótlást igényel abban az
esetben, hogyha nem vagyunk ketózisban?
és egyáltalán nem tolerálja jól, hogyha
hogyha időnként lecsökken a
vércukorszint, ez mindig egy
pánikreakciót fog gerjeszteni a
szervezetben, amivel
stresszhormontermeléssel fog reagálni.
Tehát elsősorban adrenalinnal, ez a ez a
gyorsabbik stresszhormon és később
kortizollal, ami úgy körülbelül egy
olyan 6-12 óra után kapcsol be.
>> Ez ez azért, mert ez a pánikreakció,
mert azt érzi, hogy azonnal szükségem
van energiára, mert ha nem, akkor baj
lesz. Hát ezt cukorbetegeknél is meg
lehet figyelni, hogy amikor kicsit
túladagoljuk az inzulint nekik, akkor és
leesik a vércukruk, utánuk egy fél nap
erejéig, ilyen 200 fölötti cukraik
vannak. Ez egy hipoglikémiát követő
reaktív hiperglikémia, így mondják
tudományos nyelven. Tehát, hogy a
szervezet egész egyszerűen minden
eszközzel azon van, hogy magasan tartsa
a vércukrokat, hogy nehogy még egyszer
leessen a cukorszínt. Tehát az agy
annyira fél egy következő
hipoglikémiától, mert hát az nem egy
kellemes, tehát érezni se átélni se jó,
pláne hogyha hogyha súlyosabb. Mondjuk
itt itt van egy olyan dolog is, hogy aki
hozzá van szokva a közepesen magas vagy
magasabb vércukorszintekhez,
ott már egy normális cukorszín is
okozhat, úgy mondják,
pzeudohipoglikémiát. Tehát hogy hogy a
tünetek megegyeznek a hipoglikéviával,
de a cukor normális. Tehát hogyha
valakinek 200-as volt a cukra, és most
így nagy hirtelen a diéta vagy
gyógyszerek hatására 90 lesz, azt ő
hipoglikémiának fogja megélni, mert ő
nagy a különbség. De ez egy normális
cukor, tehát egészen 70-ig mi
normálisnak tartjuk a vércukrokat, és
nem feltétlen javaslunk beavatkozást, de
abban a beteg, abban az esetben, ha
beteg tényleg rosszul van és
szimptomatikus, akkor mit tudom én,
ilyenkor mondjuk, hogy igyon meg egy kis
kefircán jaurtot, vagy egyen meg pár
cikk almát, az segí, de semmi esetre se
kell ilyenkor cukrot vegyen a beteg,
mert az az csak súlyosbíthatja a
tüneteket.
említetted a a ketó diétát, és egy
kicsit beszélnék magáról a ketóról és a
carnivorról, hogy bevezessük, hogy az
aki nem ismerős, az akik az akinek új ez
az étrend, akkor tudja nagyjából, hogy
mik a szabályok ezzel kapcsolatban, meg
mi is az értelme ennek, mi történik így
a mi az a ketózis és mi történik ebbe a
diétába.
>> Ezek szélsőségesebb, úgy hívják,
eliminatorikus diéták, amikor kivesszünk
bizonyos illelmiszercsoportokat az
étrendből. ketogén étrendben kivesszük a
szénhidrátokat úgy, úgy nagyrészt. Tehát
a klasszikus ketogén diéta az a
kalóriabbevitel 80%-át zsírból
biztosítja, egy olyan 15-20%-ot
fehérjéből és nagyon minimálisat 2%
körülbelül, tehát olyan 20 g
szénhidrátot engedélyez. Na most ezt a
diétát elsősorban
az epilepszia kezelésére dolgozták ki,
de aztán rájöttek, hogy nagyon jól lehet
például cukorbetegséget is menedzselni
vele. Azt kell tudni, hogy mindenki fél,
hogy hogy keto ketogén diéta, mert hogy
nagyon sokan asszociálják a
ketoacidózissal a ketózist, de a kettő
nem ugyanaz. Vannak átfedések a két
folyamat között, de az egyik az egy
kórros, potenciálisan életveszélyes
állapot, és elsősorban inzulinhiányos
betegeknél jelentkezik, mint az egyes
típusú cukorbetegség. A ketozis az pedig
egy teljesen fiziológiás, tehát élettani
folyamat, egy alkalmazkodó képesség a
test részéről. Tehát egész egyszerű
példa, hogy a kisbabák amikor
megszületnek, akkor ketózisba kerülnek,
tehát elvágódik a küldökzsinor, az
anyától már nem kapnak cukorutánpótlást.
Ők még tehát az emésztésük az nem igazán
indul be. Az anyatejtermelés az
általában az első nap, első pár napban
még nincsen jelen, csak ez a kolosztrum,
az előtej termelődik.
És a babák még nem igazán,
tehát nem is igazán tudják felhasználni
a cukrokat így a a az első pár napban.
És akkor ők egy ilyen ketózis állapotba
kerülnek. Tehát nem véletlen, hogy ugye
a szülészeten mérik a súlyukat a
babáknak, és akkor azt tapasztalják a az
anyukák is, meg az orvos is, hogy
visszaesik a súlya. Ez emiatt van, hogy
beindul a zsírégetés a testükben, és ezt
a kolosztrum az előtegy támogatja. Tehát
az nagyon gazdag fehérjébe, zsírokban,
nagyon alacsony szénhidrát tartalma.
Egész egyszerűen
nem
nem fokozza, indukálja az
inzulintermelést a babában, mert az
inzulin beindulna és elkezdene
termelődni, akkor leállna ketózis, de
még nincs anyatej, tehát hogy hogy
kicsit kontraproduktív lenne a dolog. De
hogy amúgy felnőtteknél is jelentkezik
ez a ketózis. Éjszaka amikor alszunk,
főleg a hajnali órákban, amikor már
elfogytak a a napközben elraktározott
cukrok a májból és az izmokból.
és böjtidőszakukban, vagy amikor
nagyon-nagyon
erős ilyen fizikai aktivitást végzünk,
akkor is ketúzisba kerülhetünk. Tehát ez
voltaképpen azt jelenti, hogy cukor
helyett zsírt kezd el használni a
szervezet, és ebből állít elő energiát,
és ezzel tartja fenn magát. Ez egy
sokkal kiegyensúlyozottabb
energiaszintet ad, mint a cukor. Tehát a
cukor általában hullámzást okoz. A
zsírbontás az az kiegyensúlyozottabb. És
ahogy te is mondtad, tehát általában
arról számolnak be a betegek, hogy
energikusabbak, jobban bírják a
terhelést, jobb a koncentrációs
készségük. Sokaknál tényleg lerövidül az
alvásidő azért, mert mert annyi
energiájuk lesz, és és ez nem jelenti
azt, hogy hogy fáradtabbak lesznek,
tehát hogy kevesebb alvás is elégséges
nekik.
Úgyhogy tehát akár négy óra alvás az
megfelel más hat-nyolc órát kell
aludjon, hogy ugyanaz az eredményt
elérjen.
>> Igen. Én konkrétan 6 óra alvás a az én
igényem, hogyha ha fegyelmezetten
étkezem, hogyha előtte alkoholt iszok,
vagy valamilyen szénhidrátot este, akkor
akkor akkor érzem, hogy nem elég a 6
óra.
Igen, még a mielőtt nekifognánk a
könyvnek, ez nagyon szuper volt így
bevezetőként,
kicsit még beszélgetnék ezekről a
glüózmitorokról, és azért is érdekes a
téma, hogy amikor készültünk erre az
adásra, akkor kaptunk szponzorként
egy-egy ilyen
glükózmitort, és egyet ki fogunk majd
sorsolni a hallgatók között. Egy én én
egy Dexcom márkájú kaptam. Te te milyet
kaptál?
>> Ez egy újabb cég. Ők most próbálnak
betörni a piacra. Ö, a cégnek az a neve,
hogy ICAN, CGM, tehát ez egy 14 nap
élettartalmal rendelkező glukózmitor.
És számomra azért volt ez egy nagyon jó
kis lehetőség. Én ezelőtt már négy ilyen
Dexcom szenzort már használtam, azért,
hogy mer elég ilyen technikai
orientáltságú személy vagyok, szeretem
látni a számokat meg a diagramokat, de
tényleg eszméletlen
mélységű információt kaptam. am saját
testemmel kapcsolatban megértettem, hogy
tényleg van egy
tehát tényleg egy mintogyha egy ilyen
ilyen mechanikus szerkezet lenne a
testem, ami kiszámítható, hogy hogyan
működik. Most konkrétan múlt héten vagy
pontosan szombaton történt meg, hogy
elutaztunk Kolozsvárra és egy egész napi
vezetés után elfáradva leültem és úgy
rám jött az a a nassolhatnék
és az egyedüli dolog, ami volt, az egy
chipsz volt, de éhes voltam és tudtam,
hogy nem szabad. Így rá is ütöttem a
kezemre, de azért csak megettem egy
kicsi chipset, egy ilyen 75 gos chipset,
és majd be fogom másolni így a a most
itt láthatnák majd a a hallgatók is,
hogy eszméletlenül kiugrott így a a
vércukorszintem egy nagyon rövid ide, és
utána pedig leesett egyből, és utána
pedig egy ilyen hullámzás volt, ameddig
ki
k ki egyenesedett az a görbe. Az alvásom
sem volt, annak meg egyetlen egy 75 g-os
chipsz, igaz, hogy é gyomorra volt az.
Úgyhogy, úgyhogy tényleg azt láttam,
hogy
ez a CGM, ez a ez a glükózmitor
betekintést adott számomra arra, hogy
hogy tényleg a vércukorszintem ez egy
valósan kiszámíthatóan növekvő valami.
Nyilván nem mér mindent, úgy ahogy
mondtad, vagy lehet, hogy privátban
mondtad, hogy a fruktóz hatását nem éri
meg, az inzulint nem méri. Tehát, hogy
hogy nem látjuk azt, hogy mi történik,
ott csak sejtjük, hogy mi történik
azáltal, hogy hirtelen leesett a
vércukor szinten. Valószínűleg amiatt,
mert inzulint termelt a testem. És
amikor inzulin van a testemben, akkor
többször említetted, olyankor nem tudunk
fogyni, olyankor tároló üzemmódban
vagyunk, nem fogyó üzemmódban. És
például az az egyik, amit még így Jess
által megértettem, hogy hiába tornászok
úgy, hogy eszek egy nagy szénhidrát
adagot, és felmegy a vércukor szintem,
és akkor utána elmegyek tegyük fel
futni, vagy így egy keményen kezdek
edzeni inkább.
Jobb lenne, ha várnék vagy három órát,
ameddig stabilizálódik a
vércukorszintem, és utána edzenék egyet,
hogyha fogy az a célom, hogy fogyjak.
Tehát cukorkontroll szempontjából nem
feltétlenül kell várni, mert mert
ha az izmokat dolgoztatjuk, akkor
inzulin jelenléte nélkül is megjelenik
rajtuk az a az a kis csatorna, amin
keresztül a glükózt fel tudják venni a
vérből, és egész egyszerűen akkor nem
érsz el akkor a kiugrásokat. emésztési
szempontból viszont
lehet, hogy nem előnyös rögtön evés után
tornászni, merthogy akkor tehát egész
egyszerűen az emésztés minősége romlik.
Most lehet, hogy ez is hozzásegít a jobb
cukorkontrollhoz, mertogy ha valamit nem
tudsz megemészteni, akkor az nem is
tudod felszívni, tehát nem fog
belekerülni a vérkeringésedbe,
de megkapják a baktériumaid, mert te nem
tudtad megemészteni, és az egy erjedést
okoz.
És van egy olyan, hogy késsei
cukorválasz.
Tehát
ezt lehet, hogy hogy méri a monitor,
hogy
tehát van egy ilyen ilyen második fázisa
a cukoremelkedésnek. Ez elsősorban a
rostoknál figyelhető meg, hogy ugye mi a
rostokat nem tudjuk megemészteni, de a
bélbaktériumaink azok tudnak belőlük
ilyen rövid szénláncú zsírsavat
csinálni. És háromféle ilyen rövid
szénláncú zsírsav van.
Tehát nagyjából 70%-kal acetátta alakul,
de valamennyi, tehát hogy olyan h
20%-ban lesz propionát is belőle, és
ebből a propionátból a szervezetünk tud
glükózt csinálni. És akkor amikor az
étel egy jó pár óra után az elfogyasztás
követően leérkezik a vastag bélbe, akkor
még lehet abból egy cukorcsúcs. Ühüm.
Tehát ezért van, hogy a
>> cukorbetegeknél
>> igen, hogy időnként rá egymásra
tevődhetnek cukorcsúcsok, és ők nem is
tudják, hogy egy olyan négy-h órával
korábban fogyasztott étkezés az, ami a
kiugrást okozza.
>> Ühüm. Azt hiszem, hogy nagyon jól be is
vezettük az első témát. Tehát, hogy most
a következő részben arra gondoltam, hogy
Jessie a könyvben leír 10 egyszerű
praktikát, hogy hogyan lehet ezt a
vércukorszínt csúcsot letörni, hogy
kisebb legyen. És az első praktika, amit
ajánlott, az az, hogy kezdjük az
étkezést rostokban gazdag étellel. És
most említetted is, hogy ennek konkrét
oka van. Mi a véleményed erről ezt erről
a praktikáról, hogy tényleg az é izét,
tehát hogy most van egy tányér előttünk
és vannak rostok rajta és esetleg
említsünk pár olyan ételt, amiben vannak
rostok, és akkor utána, tehát hogyha
először azt tesszük meg, mi lesz a
pozitív hatása annak, hogyha hogyha
először azzal kezdjük és nem tegyük fel
a a szénhidrátokkal. Először is azt
fogom megemlíteni, hogy Jessia könyvét
azzal kezdi, ha jól emlékszem, már elég
rég olvastam, hogy elmagyarázza, hogy a
növény melyik részei a legcukrosabbak.
És azt kell tudni, hogy a növény úgy
cukorból áll, tehát minden egyes
komponens se tartalmaz valamilyen
formában a cukrot. És az elején a
beszélgetésünknek már szó esett arról,
hogy a a rostok is egyfajta cukor. Tehát
például a a cellulóz az egy az egyfajta
cukor.
Na most Jess azt is megemlíti, hogy az
olaszoknál nagy divata, az antepaste,
tehát hogy a a laskaételt vagy a a
keményítőtartalmú étkezést megelőzi egy
saláta.
És ő ezt hozza fel példának. van benne
ráció, nem mindegy, hogy milyen
forrásból származik az a róstin, de
szeretnék kilyukadni.
Tehát ugye említettem, hogy a növénynek
minden egyes része
tartalmaz valamilyen formában cukrot.
A legmagasabb cukortartalommal
rendelkeznek így lentről felfele haladva
a gyökértermisek és a gumók, tehát
murok, petrezsejemzeller,
ciklahagyma, fokhagyma, gumó, a krumpli,
a földi mogyoró.
A a száris a levél tartalmazza a
legkevesebb cukrot emészthetőségi
szempontból. Tehát hogyha már rostot
akarunk fogyasztani, akkor inkább ebből
a kategóriából válasszunk.
És akkor jönnek a gyümölcsök, ami ugye
glükózt és fruktózt tartalmaz.
Itt is vannak különbségek az érett és a
kevésbé érett gyümölcsök között. És ha
majd lesz lehetősége, akkor ezt is
megindoklom, hogy miért. És akkor vannak
a termések, tehát a magvak, mint a
gabona, tehát ide búzaárparos, zab,
rizs, kukorica, minden beletartozik,
amik a növénynek a kicsinyei, és mivel
abból ki kell fejlődjön egy újabb
növény, ezért nagyon magas
cukortartalommal rendelkeznek. Tehát még
egyszer, a növény cukorból építkezik,
tehát szén szénből, szénhidrát
molekulákból, és ebből rakja össze
magát, tehát a kicsinyébe belenyom egy
csomó cukrot, úgyhogy nagyon kicsi
helyen, nagyon koncentráltan, nagyon sok
cukor található.
Tehát étkezést megelőzően jó a rost,
hogyha elsősorban valamilyen levélsalát
fogyasztunk, vagy mit tudom én,
zellerszálat. Még szintén jó jó hatásúak
ebből a szempontból a gyökértermések,
mert bár van bennük cukor, de de nagyon
rostosak, és ez a rost megköti a cukrot,
tehát nem fog hozzáadódni ahhoz, amit mi
a következő fogással elfogyasztunk.
rostok között tehát két rostot kell
megkülönböztessünk.
Vannak az oltható rostok és az
olthatatlan rostok. És nekünk elsősorban
az oltható rostok kellenek. Tehát azok,
amik képesek megszívni magukat
nedvességgel és gélesedni.
Miért jó ez? Azért, mert amikor
>> tudná pár példát mondani erre. Hát
például a pektin, inulin,
a guárgumi,
betaglükán, tehát hogy ezek zöldségek
gyümölcs hát bármilyen zöldség
gyümölcsben nagyjából ezek
megtalálhatóak. Tehát ami olthatatlan
rost, az például a korpa, tehát hogy a
héja a a magvaknak azzal nem tudunk mit
kezdeni. Tehát, hogy amit konkrétan
viszont látunk a székletben, mint a nem
véletlen, hogy a a kukoricaszemeket azok
mindig ott sárgán virítanak, tehát hogy
azt nem igazán tudjuk megemészteni. Üm
jó, tehát hogy hogy ezek mivel
megszívják magukat nedvességgel, éppen
körbeveszik az ételt, és azzal, hogy
körbeveszik az ételt, nem engedik, hogy
hozzáférjenek az emésztőenzimek, és
ezáltal nagyon-nagyon lelassul,
megnehezül az emésztési folyamat. Ennek
az lesz a következménye, hogy egész
egyszerűen tehát mivel megdzadnak sok,
tehát a a gyomorsav is tartalmaz
valamennyi folyadékot, vizet, mivel
megdzad az a az a róst és zselésedik,
ezért fes feszíti a gyomornak a falát.
Gyomorban vannak ilyen, hogy mondják,
mehanoreceptorok, amik érzik, hogy
mennyire van tele a gyomor. Minél inkább
tele van, annál később fog kiürülni,
mert annál több időt fog igénybe venni a
az emésztési folyamat. Ezek a rostok,
amikor tovább jutottak a vékony bélbe,
akkor tehát ezt ezt bizonyos baktériumok
azért elkezdik bontani, amivel rövid
színláncú zsírsavak képződnek. Ezek
tudnak aktiválni bizonyos, úgy mondják,
inkretineket, tehát ilyen hormon
hormonokat a belekben, amik
visszacsatolnak a a gyomorhoz, tehát
lassítják a gyomorürülést, az agyban jól
lakottság érzetet fokozzák. Ilyeneket mi
szoktunk használni cukorbetegeknél is.
Szintén ilyen injekciós vagy tablettás
készítmények. az ózempik is ide
tartozik, ami aminek pont ezt a hatását
használjuk ki, hogy hogy csökkenti az
étvá, tehát ezt rostokkal is el lehet
érni. Ami kontraproduktív
a rostfogyasztással kapcsolatosan. És
itt Jessivel nem feltétlen ír értünk
egyet, hogy neki a felsorolásban a
második vagy a harmadik pontban
szerepel, hogy a szénhidrát elő tegyünk
a zsírokat, illetve fehérjét.
>> Pontosan ez a második tanácsa. Úgyhogy
akkor beszéljünk erről.
Igen. Tehát, hogy tehát, hogy itt a a
rost lehet egy kicsit kontraproduktív,
azért, mert tehát meg kell értsük, hogy
hogy emésztődnek a cukrok, főleg a
keménynyítő. Tehát a keménynyítő bontása
az már a szájban megkezdődik. Ott van
egy alfa amilázenzim,
ami elkezdi bontani a keményítőt. Ezért
volt az, hogy régen például nem volt,
tehát faluhen nem volt csokoládé, nem
volt divatos a csokoládé, nem is volt
elérhető. A gyerekek vágytak valami
édesre, és akkor a szülők, hogy kicsit
lecsillapotják a lecsillapítsák a
sivalkodó porontyokat, így összegyúrtak
egy ilyen kis labdába kenyér galacsint,
és azt adták a gyereknek, hogy
szopogassa. És amikor a gyerek
szopogatta, a nyában található
amillázzim az kioldotta a keményítőből a
glüózt, és előbb-utóbb ilyen édes ízt
kezdett érezni a szájában, tehát hogy
hogy sokkal édesebb lett, minél jobban
szopogatta azt a kenyérgalacsint.
És ugye ez történik, hogy ez az enzím
kezdi lebontani a keményítőt. Igen, de
ahhoz, hogy az enzim aktív maradjon,
ahhoz neki egy semleges vagy enyhén
lugos közegre van szüksége. Viszont
amikor a gyomorba érkezik, a gyomor az
savas. És például a a fehérjéknek és a
zsíroknak ez a logikája, hogy fokozzák a
gyomorsavasságát.
Ha az enzim, tehát ez az alfaamiláz
inaktiválódik, akkor a keményítőnek a
bontása leáll addig arra az időszakra,
amíg a a keményítő a gyomorban van.
Tehát amíg ott emésztődik az étel, addig
egész egyszerűen cukorfelszívódás
nincsen. Na most a rostok ezt egy
kicsikét megakadályozhatják, mert rostok
ugye felszívják a gyomorsavat, erről az
előbb beszéltem. Másrészt viszont
bázikus vegyhatásúak, tehát csökkentik a
savasságot. Tehát hogyha a rostok után
esszük a keményítőt,
és az a rost az például nem oltható
rost, hanem olthatatlan, ami nem képesz
zselét, akkor nem biztos, hogy ugyanazt
a hatást elérjük, amit mi szeretnénk.
Tehát hogy hogy csökkenti a cukornak a
felszívódását. azt mindenképpen elérjük,
hogy hogy teltségérzet fokozódik, az
étvágy csökken, kevesebbet fogunk enni
nagy valószínűséggel, de ez se
garantált, hogyha hogyha például nagy
társaságban étkezünk, olyankor az ember
hajlamos többet enni, attól függetlenül,
hogy mennyire éhes. Tehát, hogy ez is
így
környezet és körülményfüggő.
>> Körülményfüggő.
>> Körülményfő. Igen, a harmadik és
visszacsatolunk majd az első másodikhoz,
mert valójában a harmadik tanácsai is
hasonló. Azt mondja, hogy kerüljük a
csupa szénhidrátokat. Tehát amikor csak
önmagában egy szénhidrátot eszünk,
amikor ő egy meg egy látunk egy
croasound nagyon finomnak, frissen
jönne, hogy beleharab, de sokkal jobb,
hogyha valamivel idézőjelbe
felöltöztetjük. Ezt mondja Jessie, hogy
együnk mellé valamilyen salát, vagy
valamilyen sonkát. Tehát önmagában csak
úgy ne együk. És ide visszajön az én
tapasztalatom a chipszel, amivel meg a
diagramját be is rakjuk, hogy tényleg
azt tapasztaltam, hogy aznap este
éreztem a testemen, hogy csak csupán az
a chipsz önmagában mit okozott a
testemben. Elvileg a chipsz tartalmaz
valamennyi zsírt is, úgyhogy azt kellett
volna lassítsa a cukornak a
felszívódását,
de való igaz, hogy egy nagyon, tehát egy
ultrafeldolgozott élelmiszer, rost,
nehezen emészthető komponens már nem
nagyon van benne azon a pár
zsírmolekulán kívül.
Igen, tehát csupas szénhidrátok soha nem
fordultak elő a természetben így, ahogy
most vannak, és ezért nem tudott
alkalmazkodni hozzá a szervezetünk.
Tehát egész egyszerűen hirtelen nagy
mennyiségbe beérkező cukorral nem tud
mit kezdeni a test. Tehát ilyen ilyen
pánikol és mindenféle védekező
reakciókba kezd.
Tehát igen, ahogy te is említetted,
megváltozik az ételeknek a glikémiás
indexe aszerint, hogy hogy valamit
eszünk-e mellé. Mit jelent a glikémiás
index? Hogy milyen hirteles, milyen
mértékben emeli meg a vércukors szintet?
Tehát például egy fehér kenyérnek a
glikémiás indexe nagyjából 100-as így
önmagában, de hogyha azt a kenyeret
azt egy napig szárítottuk és kicsit meg
is pirítottuk, tehát a friss kenyérnek
mindig magasabb a glikémiás indexe.
Egész egyszerűen azért, mert
ugye benne is keményítő található, és
amikor azt a kenyeret mi készítjük,
akkor összegyúrjuk ugye a lisztet a
vízzel
és
dagasztjuk és
pihentetjük és azáltal a keményítő
molekula megszívja magát nedvességgel,
átitatódik, megduzzad, és hű hatására
pedig nagyon instabillá válik. Ezért a
friss kenyér mindig könnyebben nem
ézthető ebből a szempontból, tehát a
cukor könnyebben nem ézthető és hamarabb
emeli a vércukorszinteket. De ha már egy
napos azz a kenyér, vagy meg is
pirítottuk, akkor a benne található
keményítő kezd visszakristályosodni.
Ezt például lehet fokozni fagyasztással.
A fagyasztás az nagyon felgyorsítja ezt
a visszakristályosodást.
Tehát egy ilyen kenyérszelektnek már a
glikémiás indexe, hogy körülbelül 50-es.
Hogyha megkenjük egy kevés vajjal, akkor
már 25-ösre lehet lecsökkenteni, mert a
vaj annyira lelassítja a cukroknak az
emésztését. De ez glikémiás index, tehát
hogy nem inzulinx. Az inzulinindexben
nincsen különbség. Tehát, hogy
ugyanakkora inzulinválaszt vált ki mind
a három variánsa annak a
kenyérszeletnek.
És amennyibe fogyni szeretnénk, ezt is
figyelembe kell vegyük, hogy milyen
inzulinválaszt vált ki a testünkből.
Tehát, hogy abban nincsen különbség.
Tehát cukorkontroll szempontjából van,
de inzulin szempontjából nincsen.
>> A az egyik dolog, amit most így eszembe
jutott, miközben így mondtad, hogy van
egy pár ilyen tévhit így az emberek
körében, amit én is elhittem, mint
például az, hogy a barna kenyér jobb,
mint a fehér kenyér, vagy a barnacukor
jobb, mint a a fehér cukor. És azt
mondta Jessie, hogy valójában a cukor az
cukor. Mindegy, hogy milyen színű, vagy
milyen áll állagú. Ilyen szempontból,
hogy ha bevisszük azt a mennyiséget, a
testünk ugyanúgy fog rá reagálni. erről
mi a véleményed?
>> Igen, lényegi különbségek nincsenek
közöttük.
Hát a a jó minőségű barnacukor az
tartalmaz valamennyi melaszt, attól
barna. Az olcsó fajta barnacukor ahhoz
általában
visszaadnak kevés ilyen karamellizált
cukrot, vagy egy kevés melasz, de
lényegében sima kristálycukor, amit egy
kicsit megbarítottak valami egyébbel.
Igen. Ugyanez a helyzet a barna
kenyérrel is, hogy hogy karamellel vagy
malátacukorral van, hogy
ezt a barnás színt elérik. Tehát, hogy
ez nem a lisztnek a főleg tehát
általában nem a lisznek a tulajdonsága,
azért a teljes kiölésű kenyerek azok
inkább olyan halvány, barna, szürkés
színűek, tehát hogy az inkább a a liszt
miatt olyan.
cukorszempontból, inzulin válasz
szempontjából nincsenek lényegi
különbségek. A teljes kérlésű kenyér
valamivel több rostot tartalmaz.
Ez a rost, ez féligmeddig oltható,
olthatatlan rost, de annyira finomra van
őrülve, hogy egész egyszerűen
nem feltétlen úgy viselkedik a
szervezetben, mint egy normális rostul
az elvárható lenne. Tehát, hogy nem
olyan az a az a finomra darált liszt,
mintogyha elropogtatnánk egy répát.
Tehát nem fogja ugyanazt a hatást,
ugyanazt a cukorcsökkentő hatást
kiváltani, mert annyira finomra le van
kicsinyítve. Tehát
>> nagyon apróra van darálva. A következő,
amit Jessie javasolt, az az, hogy
használjunk ecetet étkezés előtt. Ez Ezt
te is próbáltad?
>> Igen,
>> amúgy én is próbáltam, nem túl kellemes,
de meg lehet szokni. Igazából egy pár
nap alatt már megszoktam, és és tényleg
azt látom, hogy a közérzeten változik,
de kicsit mesélj erről. Ez miért jó a
testünk számára? Hát az ecet úgy
általában nagyon egészséges, mert egy
probiotikus, tehát amennyiben fermentált
ecetről van szó, az egy probiotikus
készítmény. És régen például
a légionáriusok, tehát ilyen hadjáratok
alkalmával a ecetes vizet ittak, mert
egész egyszerűen nem mindig volt
lehetőség arra, hogy felfőzzék a vizet,
ahogy meneteltek. Tehát volt úgy gyorsan
tovább kellett állni egyik táborból a
másikba, és akkor tisztítatlanul kellett
inni azokat a forrásfizeket, vagy éppen
ami akad. És az ecet annak van egy
antibakteriális hatása, tehát nagyon jól
véd az ékolli, a kandida, szalmonella
ellen.
Ez az egyik dolog, és támogatja a
jótékony bélbaktériumokat.
A benne található baktériumok
elpusztulnak, mert vannak benne
baktériumok, de azok elpusztulnak a
gyomosrav hatására, de hogy
elpusztulnak, ilyen prebiotikumok
képződnek belőlük, a viszont ami viszont
már a mi mi flóránkat támogatja, tehát
felerősíti.
Az ecetnek ezenkívül van egy olyan jó
tulajdonsága is, hogy egy picit
irritálja a gyomrot és ezért fokozza a
gyomorossav termelést. Az előbb már szó
volt a gyomosavról, hogy ugye savas
közegben inaktiválódik az amilázzenzim,
tehát lelassul a keményítőnek az
emésztése. Ez az egyik dolog. Tehát
ezért jó egy cukorbetegnek szénhidrátot
tartalmazó étkezés előtt ecetet inni, de
van egy másik aspektus is, hogy a
gyomorban még nem szívódnak fel a
cukrok, csak a patkóbélből, tehát a
gyomor után következő szakaszon. És a
gyomor és a patkóbél között van egy
záróizom,
amin vannak ilyen, úgy mondják,
kemoreceptorok, tehát amik érzékelik,
hogy mennyire savas
étel fog átjutni a gyomorból a patkó
bélbe.
Az a helyzet, hogy a a gyomrot védi egy
nyákréteg, ami nem engedi, hogy
korodálja őt a sav, de a patkóbélben ez
már nincsen jelen. Tehát a
patkóbélbe-ben, hogyha bejött egy nagyon
savas
ilyen bél benne, tehát egy ilyen egy
ilyen adag étel, az komoly károkat tud
okozni. És ezért nagyon-nagyon le kell
lassítani az átjutást, mert ezen a ezen
a záróizmon itt körben vannak ilyen
lugosító kicsi sejtecskék, amik amik
lugot termelnek és semlegesítik a sav.
De ahhoz, hogy ez a a ez kellően
összekeveredjen az ételles, kellő
mértékben tudja semlegesíteni a savat,
azt kell, hogy egyszerre csak kicsi
mennyiség tudjon átjutni a záróizm.
Ezért amikor a záróizom érzékelő nagyon
savas a gyomortartalom, összehúzódik,
csak nagyon pici mennyiségeket enged el.
Ezzel nagyon le lehet lassítani az
emésztési folyamatot, tehát a a gyomor
tovább marad tele étellel. Így később
fogunk megéhezni.
És le lehet lassítani a cukroknak a
felszívódását, tehát mind a két
hatásmechanizmussal, a gyomoravassággal,
illetve a lassú gyomorürüléssel.
>> Hm. eszméletlen. A következő tippe tipje
Jessinek az volt, hogy evés után
mozogjunk valamennyit, tehát egy 10
percet. Hogyha nem tudunk egyebet
csinálni, akkor 30 guggolás is megteszi,
vagy hogyha egy irodai környezetben
vagyunk, akkor le tudunk például sétálni
és fel a lépcsőn. Ugyanis azt mondta,
hogy az izmok ilyenkor azt a többlet
glükózt valamennyire felszívják, főleg a
nagyobb izmok a a testben. Erről mi a
véleményed? Ő úgy írja a könyvében, hogy
evés után egy olyan 10-20 perccel, de a
20 perc az már túl sok. Tehát, hogy a
cukrok azok nagyjából egy olyan 15 perc
után, tehát hogyha magukba fogyasztjuk
őket, akkor azok már átjutnak a
gyomorból a patkópillba, és elkezdenek
felszívódni, és már elkezdik emelni a
vércukorszintet, mire mi odajutunk, hogy
mozogjunk valamit. Kettő, hogy
az evés után végzett mozgás az általában
rontja az emésztést, ami nem biztos,
hogy szeretnénk. Tehát a legtöbb
embernél pont az a probléma, hogy hogy
emésztési problémák vannak jelen. És
hogy ez erre még nem akarunk rátenni egy
lapát. Tehát ezért is van, hogy régen
mondták, hogy hogy futtában nem esszünk.
Tehát, hogy
engem is mindig szidott nagymamám, hogy
hogy amikor én jövök, megyek az utcán,
akkor ne mind rákicsáljak a kiflit vagy
perecet, merthogy akkor még nem tudtam,
glutén érzékeny vagyok, de h hogy
ilyeneket ne egyek, mert hogy ez nem
egészséges. És ők tudtak valamit, tehát
érdemes az öregekre odafigyelni,
merthogy igen, tehát hogy és a
háziasszonyoknál is, tehát a
háziasszonyokra az jellemző, hogy nem
tudnak két percát nyugot nyugton ülni az
asztalon, állandóan fel ugrálnak, hogy
hogy mindenkit kiszolgáljanak maguk
körül. és ők nem tudnak nyugodtan enni,
és ezért van, hogy hamarabb híznak.
Tehát ez egyfajta stresszt generál, hogy
nem tudunk nyugodtan emészteni.
És a stressz hatására kortizol kezd
termelődni, ami megrontja az emésztést,
tehát csökkenti a gyomorsav termelést,
leállítja a a bélmozgásokat, tehát nem
keveredik az étel az emésztőenzimekkel,
azokból amúgy nincs is elég. Ö, és hogy
általában ö tehát stresszes helyzetben
hányinger vagy hasmenés szokott
bekövetkezni nagyon extrém esetben,
tehát hogy mindenképpen romlik az
emésztés. Tehát, hogy ez nem feltétlen
tesz jót nekünk, ha cukorkontol
cukorkontroll szempontjából van is
logika abban, amit mond. Én inkább azt
javasolnám, hogy éheztessük ki az
izmokat evés előtt. Tehát csináljunk pár
darab gugolást, mert ezzel is ki lesznek
éheztetve az izmok, és akkor már ahogy
fogyasztjuk azt az ételt, azonnal kezdik
elszívni a vérből a cukrot. Tehát ők
inzulin hiányában is képesek felvenni a
cukrokat, hogyha meg vannak dolgoztatva.
Úgyhogy én azt javasolnám, hogy inkább
evés előtt mozogjunk, és ne utána.
>> Tehát egy 10 perc séta evés előtt az,
ami például ideális. Hát ö időseknél, de
kondicionált embereknél mindenképpen,
azoknál az embereknél, akik viszont
képesek kicsit többre is, vagy hogy
eredményeket is szeretnének látni, tehát
hogy izmosodni szeretnének, vagy vagy
nagyon jó cukorkontrollt szeretnének,
fogyni szeretnének, azoknál inkább
izomtömegemelés, tehát hogy valami olyan
gyakorlatot végezzenek saját testúlyal
vagy súlyzóval, ami ami jobban
megdolgoztatja az izmokat. De nem kell
ez sok legyen. Tehát elég egy 5-10 perc
maximum.
>> Ühüm. A következő tipje Jessinek az
volt, hogy a reggeli, tehát kezdjük a
reggelt sós reggelivel, ne pedig
édessel. Így elmesélte, hogy az
édesanyja narancs juice ívott reggelire
és és műzlitev vett, és ez ez
hihetetlenül fellövi a vércukorszintet.
De kezdjük valami sóssal, valami olyan
dologgal, ami egy egy tojásrántotta,
vagy egy sonka, vagy vagy valami olyan,
ami ami amúgy a székely konyházhoz
hozzátartozik.
Igen. Tehát, hogy ebben van nagyon sok
tudomány ez a emögött az állítás mögött,
tehát hogy reggel általában magasabbak a
vércukorszintek és jobb, tehát nagyobb
az inzulinrezisztencia, tehát az
ellenállás a cukorcsökkentéssel szemben.
>> Úgy általában jobban stabilizálja az
energiaszinteket, hogyha valamilyen
fehérjével indítjuk a napot, és később
is fogunk megéhezni, mert általában a
fehérjék adják a a legnagyobb jól
lakottságérzetet. Tehát azzal bírjuk a
legtovább, hogy hogy a következő
étkezésig. Ezenkívül a a termikus hatása
az ételeknek, tehát hogy mennyi energiát
igényel a megemésztése, ott is a
fehérjéke a legmagasabb. Tehát, hogy
mennyi energiát kell belefektessen a
szervezet abba, hogy először is azt az
ételt megemészse, felszívja, utána
szállítsa és és felhasználja különböző
célokra a testben. És itt a fehérje
szokott vezetni.
Hogy miért só?
Tehát egyrészt kell a só a gyomorsav
termeléshez, reggel szokott a
legmagasabb szinten lenni a gyomorsav
termelés. Ezért is logikus, hogy a
legnehezebb ételeket reggel fogyasszuk.
Tehát a fehérjéket is, zsírokat azt
inkább reggelre kell
tehát időzíteni, mert akkor tud a
szervezetünk a legkönnyebben megbirkózni
vele. Én emlékszem, hogy a férjemmel
egyszer elmentünk Angliába, és ott van
ez a tipikus English breakfast, ami
nagyjából fehérje és zsír, tehát hogy
még a paradicsomot is olajba kisütötte a
háziasszony. És azt kell tudni, hogy hét
hónapos terhes voltam, de egy ilyen
reggeli után, ami nem volt egy nagy
adag, de nagyon tartalmas volt. Hát úgy
körülbelül este 8-9-ig én abszolút nem
kívántam egész nap semmit. Tehát
járkáltunk, mi azok a fajta turisták
vagyunk, akik inkább megyünk és
nézelődünk, tehát nem a tengerparton
szeretjük süttetni a hasunkat. A és hát
egész nap jöttünk, mentünk, mindent
megnéztünk, amit egyszer csak lehetett,
és nem éheztünk meg, pedig azért volt
ott fizikai terhelés, tehát egy egy
ilyen reggeli, és sokan mondják nekem a
cukorbetegek közül is, hogy de nehéz
fizikai munkát végeznek, és hogy nem
bírják kenyér nélkül. Ez nem igaz. A
zsírok sokkal kiegyensúlyozottabbtabb,
tartósabb energi szintet adnak, mint
mint például a cukorfogyasztás. És ha
például reggelire gyümölcsleveket, ami
nagyon gyorsan felszívódó, cukoroldat
vagy fehér kenyeret, vagy általában
kenyeret fogyasztunk, inkább az
destabilizálja a a vércukorszinteket.
>> A következő
javaslata Jessinek az volt, hogy ha
deszertet akarunk enni, akkor és már így
is, úgy is szeretnénk fogyasztani, akkor
étkezés után fogyasszuk a deszertet, ne
pedig előtte. És azt hiszem, hogy ez
visszacsatolódik ahhoz a sorrendiséghez,
amit beszéltünk, hogy hogy egyrészt ne
együnk deszertet önmagára, ha lehet, és
hogyha eszünk, akkor akkor a sorrendben
az a a végére kerüljön, mert az
emisztísi sorrend is hasonló lesz, ahogy
ahogyan bevisszük a szervezetünkbe.
>> Igen. Én általában a cukorbetegeknek azt
szoktam javasolni, hogy lehetőleg egy
deszert legyen egy nap, nem tiltom el
őket tőlük. Tehát az életben megvannak a
a az adott örömök, ami amihez
mindenkinek joga van, és kellenek is,
hogy hogy egy kicsit valahogy
elviselhetőbbé tegyük a mindennapokat.
De hogy igen, erre jó odafigyelni, hogy
nem kétkezés között vagy csak úgy
rendasszuk őket, hanem igenis tudatosan.
És ahogy az előbb már szó volt róla,
tehát
a desszertek általában a leggyakoribb
esetben ilyen ultrafeldolgozott
élelmiszerek szoktak lenni, még akkor
is, hogyha otthon készül az a sütemény.
Tehát az emberek általában valamilyen
édességet, süteményt szoktak asszociálni
a deszertel. bár a méz, lekvár, szörpők,
gyümölcsök és desesszert kategóriának
számítak, sőt még az édes tej is, mert
hogy az is egy cukor, tehát hogy nagyon
sok benne a tejcukor. Ö és hogy azért
kellene ezeket étkezés után fogyasztani,
merthogy a a főétkezésbe található
zsírok, fehérjék azok nagyon lelassítják
a a bennük található cukroknak a
felszívódását, és ezáltal az
inzulinválaszt is mérséklik, tehát
kevésbé lesz terhelő a szervezet
számára, mint önmagába fogyasztva.
>> A következő tanácsod Jessinek az volt,
hogy kerüljük a turmixot, ha kerüljük az
ilyen séeket, kerüljük a a az ilyen
gyümölcsleveket. És itt gyakorlatilag
elmondja a könyvben az az, hogy hogy
ameddig meg tudunk enni egy banánt, vagy
maximum kettőt, addig egy ilyen egy
ilyen banánségbe belerakunk nagyon sok
gyümölcsöt, és és sokkal többet
fogyasztunk el ilyenkor, mint amennyit
amúgy meg tudnánk enni.
És ez hihetetlenül fel
megnöveli a a vércukorszintünket. A
másik pedig az, hogy ilyenkor a rostok
egyrészt vagy kikerülnek belőle, vagy
pedig gondolom, hogy feldarálódnak a a
ebbe a sébe.
És ez bizonyos szempontból olyan furcsa
is, mert ez a sékkultúra ez pont a
divatját éli most, hogy hogy mindenki
séeket iszik és és így próbál fogyni, és
így próbál
étrendet változtatni. Úgy most akkor
kicsit segíts nekem be tiszta vizet
önteni a sébe.
>> Hát hát nem mindegy, hogy milyen sékről
beszélünk.
Tehát, hogy hogy azért az alapanyagok
itt is
tehát hogy úgy meghatározzák, hogy hogy
milyen reakciót váltanak ki a
szervezetből. Tehát hogy például egy
hogyha ilyen bugyós gyümölcsöket eszünk
abba a sébe meg saláta levelet, vagy
spenótlevelet, akkor az nem feltétlen ad
egy magas glikémiás választ, mert úgy
attól függetlenül, hogy tönkretesszük a
rostokat az aprítással, úgy általában
nagyon alacsony a szénhidráttartalma
ezeknek a gyümölcsöknek. De ha igen,
tehát hogyha banánt vagy egyéb
gyümölcsöt teszünk hozzá, az már egy
másik történet. Ha tejet öntünk hozzá,
az megint egy másik történet. Ha mézet
teszünk, akkor az meg már teljesen
elrontja a dolgot. Azért
>> kicsit mesélj ezekről, mint akkor mi
történik a a mézzel, meg mi történik a
tejjel ilyenkor a séekben? Tehát, hogy
azért szeretik az emberek a sé, merthogy
minden, ami oldtatban van, az nem
igényel
emésztést, és szinte azonnal átjut a
bélfalon. Tehát, hogy egy csomó
mikrotápanyaghoz nagyon könnyen, gyorsan
és minimális emésztést igényelve hozzá
tudunk jutni. De pont ez a hátulütő is,
tehát hogy hogyha mi mézet teszünk ebbe,
vagy olyan gyümölcsöt, aminek magasabb a
glükózfruktóz tartalma, akkor ezekhez is
minimális emésztés árán fog hozzájutni a
szervezetünk, tehát hogy hogy nagyon
nagy mértékben megemeli a
vércukorszintet, és a szerberek
hajlamosak párhuzamot vonni, ahogy te is
mondtad, a a gyümölcs és a sé között.
De hogy a a gyümölcs egészen másképp
viselkedik, mertogy ott még nagyjából
érintetlennek a a rostok. A sében meg
már ezek fel vannak aprózva, meg tehát
nem csak sében, hany gyümölcslevekben
is.
Előfordul az is, hogy a gyümölcsleveket
leszűrjük. Tehát például amikor
narancsot, narancslevet iszunk, ha a
narancsot meghámozzuk, akkor van rajta
az a az a hártya, ami a cikkeket
beborítja, illetve az a fehéres réteg,
ami rögtön a héj alatt van, aminek van
egy ilyen kesernyis íze. A rostartalmat
az volt, aki épp az adja, tehát az a
fehéres részt meg a hártya. a különböző
ilyen kis narancs rostok,
>> azok már olyan magas rostartalommal nem
rendelkeznek, de ami a narancsrébe
kerül, az voltaképpen az a kicsi
kisarancsrost, ami a ami ami azt a azt a
azt a narancs darabkát, azt a elkülönül
kis komponenst, azt beborítja. Tehát az
már nem egy olyan nagy mennyiség, mint
ami a hélyba található, de a
centrifugálással azt eltüntetjük, mert
hogy azt nincs, hogy megigyük, annyira
felaprózzuk.
>> És ameddig egy narancsot tudunk megenni,
vagy kettőt, addig gondolom egy öt
narancsnak a levét is meg tudjukni
egyszerre.
>> Hát igen, mert hogy a folyadékok azok
nagyon gyorsan átjutnak a gyomron, tehát
hogy nem nagyon kell lemészük őket,
úgyhogy ahogy megittuk, az megy is
tovább. Igen, de hogy űrtartalomra is
gyakorlatilag egy narancsnak a leve az
kevés az az nem nem elegendő ahhoz, hogy
hogy a szomjunukat oltsa úgymond. Tehát
ilyenkor többre vágyunk és valószínűleg
öt narancsnak a levét isszuk meg
egyszerre.
>> Igen. Mondjuk a mindig a jó jó hatással
van, hogyha ezt felhígítjük, tehát hogy
nem koncentráltan isszuk, még akkor is,
hogyha frissen csavart narancsléról van
szó, hanem hogy kevés vízzel hígítjük.
Tehát például mi alm szoktunk készíteni,
és azt a gyerekeknek én hígított
formában adom. Nem tiltom el teljesen
tőlük őket,
tőle őket, merthogy
tehát ez egy élvezeti cikk. Ö de hogy
nem úgy kell, nem feltétlen úgy kell
felfogni, hogy
hogy egy egészségpromováló
ital, mert tehát itt a a a vitamin és az
ásványianyagtartalommal is vannak egy
picit ilyen félreértések, vagy mitoszok,
tehát hogy például a C-vitamint tartalma
az almének, tehát már ahogy a gyümölcsöt
leszedjük a fáról, a C-vitamintartalom
esik,
>> ahogy levegővel érintkezik a C-vitamin,
oxidálódik, tehát hogy tönkremegy.
gyümölcslével is ez a helyzet, hogy
megnövekedik a felület, amin eloszlik az
a C-vitamin, tehát sokkal gyorsabban
oxidálódik. Tehát abba az amalébe már
sok C-vitamin nincsen.
>> Hm. Úgyhogy
>> tehát amikor írja rajta nagy a nagy C
betűt a a terméken, akkor ez egy
bizonyos szempontból egy ilyen
szemfényvesztés,
hogy van valamennyi benne, de
>> van, hogy hozzáadnak C-vitamint, hogy az
eltarthatóságot fokozzák, de igen,
többnyire ez általában tehát, hogy a
vásárló az szeretne egészségtudatosabban
étkezni és fogyasztani, és erre
rájátszanak egy kicsikét a gyártók.
Igen. Hát gyanítom, hogy itt az a
megoldás, hogy az emberek műveltebbé
válnak, hogy elolvassák az a a nem csak
a a csomagoláson levő szép
diagramokat nézik meg, hanem a hátán van
ez a táblázat, és abból konkrétan lehet
látni, gondolom, hogy konkrétan mi is
van abba az ételbe.
>> Hát igen, itt egy másik kategória az
ilyen koncentrátumból készült
gyümölcslé.
Annak már sok köze nincsen a
gyümölcshöz, tehát hogy
>> az nagyjából egy cukros lé. ö
ízfokozókkal. Tehát hogy
>> És mi a helyzet az alkohollal? Tudom,
hogy Jess ellene van az
alkoholfogyasztásnak. Ő nem tudom, hogy
ő fogyaszt-e. Én szeretem az alkoholt,
az az igazság. És és nekem ez tényleg
egy olyan, hogy hát azért nyilván, hogy
nem naponta iszok, de hogyha van egy jó
összejövetel egy társaság, akkor akkor
akkor szeretem. De de valamiért nagyon
ellene van. Neked mi a véleményed a az
alkoholról? Hát én se feltétlen
promoválom az okolt. Tehát már
bizonyítást nyert, hogy minden
koncentráció, tehát minden mennyiségben
agyi szintű károsodásokat okoz akár egy
pohár is. Mindegy, hogy az bór vagy
sőről van szó, tehát akármilyen
alkoholkoncentráció,
az már kimutatható agyi elváltozásokat
tud eredményezni.
Azt kell tudni, hogy az tehát az alkohol
az tehát, hogy ez nagyon erős méreg
a májba kerül semlegesítésre, a cetalde
itid keletkezik belőle és egész
egyszerűen a máj nem képes addig semmi
mással foglalkozni, amíg azt azt a azt
az alkoholtoxint nem semlegesítette.
Ezért van az, hogy például, hogyha este
lefekvéskor isza valaki az alkoholt,
akkor nagyon gyakran éjszaka
hipoglikémiája van, tehát hogy leesik a
vércukors szintje, mert hogy éjszaka
elvileg a máj kellene biztosítsa a
szervezetünk számára a cukrot. Egyrészt
az elraktározott glikogénből, amit ő le
kell bontson és át kell alakítson
glüózzá. Másrészt amikor az elfogy,
akkor ő kellene új cukrot csináljon.
Egész egyszerűen a máj annyira el van
foglalva az alkohol bontásával, hogy ezt
nem tudja, semmi másról nem tud
koncentrálni, merthogy az elsődleges,
attól a méreganyagtól meg kell
szabadulni. És ezért tehát én én ne én
én a diétás betegeimnél tettem fel ilyen
cukormonitort.
Elsősorban írtük, hogy lássák, hogy a
különböző élelmiszerek azok milyen
hatással vannak a vírcukorszintjeikre.
És ott nagyon szépen látszott sokaknál,
hogy hogy behan a vércukorszint éjszaka.
Ezt nem vették észre, átaludták, nem
éreztek semmit, de elmondták, hogy
másnap fáradtabbak voltak, kevésbé
tudták megállni, hogy hogy ne egyék
azokat a komfortételeket. Mondtad te is,
hogy
egy nehéz nap után kívánod a
>> a szénhidrátot. Az olsó
>> szénhidrátot. Az olcsó szénhidrátot.
Nagyon sokaknál ez előfordul, mert mert
hogy ez egy komforttétkezés, tehát ott
vezetjük le a mindennapi stresszt.
Nem feltétlen a szervezetünknek van rá
szüksége, hanem a kicsi lelkünknek.
>> Igen.
>> A másik dolog, amiért nem tudom
javasolni az alkoholt, hogy nem
véletlen, hogy a a sesszel
fertőtlenítünk, tehát hogy annak ilyen
bakteriosztatikus
hatása van,
nagyobb koncentráció, akár baktericid is
lehet, és hogy ugye a beleinkben is
élnek baktériumok.
És ezeknek egy része nagyon érzékeny az
alkoholra, elsősorban a laktobacillusok
is, hogy ezeket úgy azért eléggé
megnyirbálja a az alkohol. Tehát mondják
is sokszor a férfiak, hogy hogy
pálinkával fertőtlenítünk hasmen és
korovitom. És ez tényleg így van. Tehát
hogy a ott az lefertőtleníti a beleket,
de nem biztos, hogy hogy jó felet.
>> Igen. Ezt általában pozitívan pozitív
kontextusban mondják, mintogyha ez egy
jó dolog lenne. De akkor azt mondod,
hogy semennyi alkohol nem jó. Ez az
egyik. És a másik, hogy akkor akkor
inkább közelítsük meg másképpen, hogyha
ha van egy jó társaság, akkor mennyi az
az ideális mennyiségű alkohol, amennyit
még esetleg elfogyaszthattok. Tehát,
hogy egy egy pohárbor az még elcsúszhat
szerinted, vagy pedig így is, úgy is
megvan annak a negatív hatása, és nincs
kiúbb ez alul. Vállaljam a
következményeit? A hát nem, tehát hát
ilyen összejövetelekkor én úgy gondolom,
hogy egy minimális mennyiség belefér,
már csak azért is, hogy az ember tudjon
ellazulni, jól érezze magát, mert azért
az alkohol egy kicsikét dezinhibál,
tehát hogy feloldja a feszültséget
és hogy hogy lazábbá tesz, tehát jobban
tudunk szocializálódni tőle. Nem
véletlen, hogy olyan sok az
alkoholizmus, főleg a férfiaknál, mert a
férfiaknál nincsenek meg ezek a kötődési
hormonok, mint például az oxitocin.
Ők inkább, tehát náluk az őt testükben a
vazopresszin termelődik, és amikor
hazajönnek egy fáradt nap után és otthon
egészen más a légkör, mint például a
munkában, akkor hirtelen kell egy ilyen
átállás, amiben nagyon gyakran segít a
az alkohol, főleg, hogyha hogyha még van
egy traumás múlt is a háttérben.
A tehát, hogy alkalmanként az alkohol
egy észszerű mennyiségben fogyasztható,
hogyha nem túl rendszeres a fogyasztás.
Most még egyszer kihangsúlyoznám, hogy
egyáltalán nem vagyok az
alkoholfogyasztás mellett. Ö teljesen
mindegy, hogy milyen típusú alkoholt
fogyasztunk, de annak, akinek bármi
gondja van a gabonák,
a glukénál például, annak kell vigyázni
a sörrel, a whkyvel, meg a hasonló
italokkal, mert hogy arra reagálhat a
szervezetük sokkal inkább, mint például,
hogyha a bort iszik. Úgyhogy most így
beszélgettünk erről a a
nem már nem is emlékszem milyen szót
használtál, de ez az érzelmi alapú
étkezésről, amikor jön a sóvárgás és
akkor magunkat meg akarjuk kicsit
simogatni.
És az az igazság, hogy ez nekem az egyik
gyengém. Tehát tudom, hogy egy stresszes
nap után amikor hazamegyek, akkor vagy
az van, hogy nagyon tudatosan küzdök, és
akkor valahogy megállom, hogy ne egyek
semmit, de de tudatos kell legyek.
Hogyha nem tudatos, akkor ilyen-olyan
dolgot csipegetek, hogy van-e valamilyen
tanácsod, hogy ilyenkor hogyan lehet ezt
a sóvárgást csökkenteni? Van-e valami,
ami nála nálad bevált esetleg? És és van
valamilyen tapasztalatod ezek, vagy
egyszerűen muszáj a belső fegyelmet
ilyenkor segítségül hívni? Hát nekem
szerencsém van, mert én általában nem az
édeset kívánom, hanem a sósat. Ez azért,
mert mert úgy alapból egy meg lehetősen
magas stresszintekkel funkcionáló ember
vagyok.
És
>> tehát a stresszhormonhoz meg, hogy a
vérnyomás fenntartásához kell a só.
Én általában tepertőt szoktam enni.
Nekem nekem az a komfortétel, nehogy
zsíros. Úgy általában a zsíros ételek az
komfort ittel meg sós.
Tehát én
ha jobb variáns, akkor azt mondanám,
hogy mit tudom, mandulát majszoljunk,
vagy
tehát gyümölcsökből az ilyen bogyós
gyümölcsöket. A csokoládé sokan sokan
mondják a a mit tudom 70-85%-os
kakaótartalmú csokoládét, de hogy az
attól még csokoládé, tehát hogy abban
vannak egyéb komponensek is, ami nem
feltétlen jó nekünk, még akkor is,
hogyha magas a kakaó tartalom, tehát
hogyha az ember kanalazza a kakaót, az
oké, de a csokoládia az egészen másképp
viselkedik a szervezetünkben, és már nem
is nem annyira pozitív pozitívum fog
megmutatkozni.
>> Igen.
>> Úgyhogy ez nem egy jó alternatíva. Hát
akkor marad a belső fegyelem, azt
hiszem, hogy mandulával például nekem az
a problémám, hogy a sós mandula, abból
nem lehet egy marékkal megni, vagy nem
lehet hármat megenni, vagy 10-et, mert
egyszerűen annyira eteti magát annyira,
hogy hogy nem tudok leállni. Úgyhogy
úgyhogy tényleg az van, hogy nálam ami
beváltod az, hogy is inkább semmit, mert
így nem tudok kicsit enni, hanem utána
beindul és utána a sóvárgás beindul. De
azt hiszem, hogy akkor akkor tényleg
nincs kiút ebből. Tehát
ez a sóvárgás, ez általában egy belső
feszültségből ered, és
tehát erre vannak levezető technikák,
tehát például a légzőgyakorlatokkal
lehet aktiválni a paraszimpatikus
integrendszert, aminek étvágycsökkentő
hatása van. Ezenkívül a jóga is, tehát
hogy amikor hazamegyünk, hát több
szempontból jó. Tehát ülőtevékenység
után a a hátizmoknak, az ízületeknek a
megmozgatásához nagyon jó egy ilyenú
ilyenkor
>> egy nyújtás. Igen. És már azzal lehet
csökkenteni az étvágyat, tehát hogy hogy
vannak egyéb elterelő hadműveletek, nem
feltétlen az ételben, tehát hogy olyan
ételt kell keressünk, ami inkább
elcsúszik. Tehát nem biztos, hogy hogy
ez a jó taktika, hanem lehet, hogy
valami egyéb tevékenység.
>> Igen. Tehát például egy vagy fizikai
tevékenység, amit mondasz, egy nyújtás,
ez ez egy jó ötlet.
Jó. A kilences javaslata Jessek
azt mondja, hogy minél kevésbé
processzált ételeket fogyasszunk. Tehát,
hogy ha most veszünk egy almát, hogyha
ketté vágjuk, az már egy processzálás,
hogyha a valamennyire, tehát az már a a
természetes formájától úgymond egy
lépéssel távolabban, és hogyha azt
meghámozzuk, akkor az még egy
processzálás, hogyha kicsavarjuk, az még
egy processzálás. És vannak a
hiperprocesszált ételek, amelyeket
amelyeknek a definíció talán az, hogy a
konyhánkban nem tudnánk el
nem tudnánk csak laboratóriumi
körülmények között tudnánk előállítani,
mint például a gyárakban, ahogy az
ételekkel bánnak, hogy az azt csak a
gyárakban lehetnek
elkészíteni. És nagy többségében azt
mondja Jessie, hogy ez a ezek a
hiperprocesszált ételek nem jók.
Fogyasszunk minél kevésbé processzált
ételt. Most nem tudom, hogy van-e ez
alól kivétel, hogy vannak-e olyan
hiperprocesszált ételek, amelyek viszont
jók. El tudom képzelni
ételkiegészítőkben, mint például te egy
fehérje por, hogy hogy az önmagában
lehet, hogy jó. De kíváncsi vagyok a
véleményedre ezzel kapcsolatban.
>> Hát én is azt szoktam ajánlani, hogy
lehetőleg a legprimitívebb formában
vásároljuk meg az élelmiszereket, és mi
otthon készítsünk belőle ételt, de
bármilyen
tehát bármilyen konyhatechnikai eljárás
már feldolgozottá teszi azt az
élelmiszert. Tehát
a a hogy mondjam, a tojás, a hús, a
zöldségek és a gyümölcsök így
önmagukban, ezek nem feldolgozott
élelmiszerek, de a sajt már igen. Tehát
>> Igen.
>> Tehát, hogy itt
tehát nagyon kevés az az élelmiszer, ami
ami nem feldolgozott formában fordul elő
a a palettánkon.
Azért is tartom helyesnek ezt az
ajánlást, mert az ult ultrafeldolgozott
élelmiszerekben általában már olyan
komponensek is vannak, amik egyéb
szempontból nem tesznek jót az
egészségünknek. Tehát ezeket az ételeket
általában
mondhatjuk, hogy fogyasztó barátok, de
inkább tehát, hogy arra mennek rá az
eladók, hogy minél többet vásároljunk
belőle, tehát hogy hogy minél
tetszetősebb legyen íz, konzisztencia,
állag, kinézetel szempontjából, még a
csomagolást is tehát ilyen
tesztcsoportokkal vizsgáltatják, hogy
melyik az, ami a leginkább szemet szúr,
és nagy harcok folynak, hogy a bevásárló
üzletek nek a melyik tehát a
szemmagasságban lévő polcokra helyezzék
el ezeket a terméket men zene menjen a
háttérbe
>> az is például meg hogy hogy az üzletben
nem tehát nem véletlenszerűen vannak
elhelyezve például a chipszek meg az
édesség ott ahol el vannak helyezve a
>> mert hogy akkor inkább vásárolunk
belőlük tehát hogy ez ez mind nem
véletlen az ízük ezeknek az ételeknek
sem véletlen. Tehát, hogy ezt ezt
komolyan tesztelik több hónapon
keresztül, mi kiválasztják a a lehető
legjobb variánst, ami a legtöbb vevőt
fogja vonzani. De ez olyan szempontból
nem vásárló barát, hogy soha senkit nem
érdekel az illetőnek az egészsége, csak
az, hogy minél többet fogyasszon az
adott termékből, tehát hogy hogy függővé
tegyen és lehetőleg
folyamatos vásárlói legyünk mi annak a
terméknek.
Ezt ízfokozókkal, különböző
adalékanyagokkal érik el, amik amikről
most már egyre több mindent lehet
olvasni különböző
ilyen információs felületeken, hogy
milyen káros hatásaik vannak. Tehát itt
egyetértünk Jessyvel. Az
ultrafeldolgozott élelmiszerek általában
gyorsabban, tehát hogy nem igényelnek
különösebb emésztést, mert hogy minden
annyira finomítva van benne, hogy hogy
szinte azonnal felszívodik, nem is kell
rágjuk, mert puhák, nincs bennük rost.
Tehát, hogy hogy ezért is hamar
megemelik például az inzulin és a
vércukors szinteket.
>> És mi a helyzet a fehérje porral?
>> Na most a rossz nyelvek azt mondják,
hogy ugye tehát a a leginkább
testsúlyépítők által használt fehérje
bor az a tejsavófehérje, tehát a Way
Protein vagy a Way Protein Isolate. És
ez egy jó minőségű fehérje, tehát
gyorsan felszívódik, be is épül az
izmokba, de hogy nem 100%-ban szívódik
fel. Tehát például a hús az sokkal jobb
minőségű fehérje, sokkal nagyobb fehérje
bevitelt biztosít, mint ezek a fehérje
porok.
Fehérje porok nagyon nagyrészt nehéz
féle fémekkel, tehát ólommal lehetnek
szennyezettek, nem nagyon kontrollálják
őket. Tehát hogy ezek
ezek ott valahol egy ilyen fehér folyt a
térképen, hogy hogy
nem számítanak
gyógyszernek, nem számítanak különösebb
élelmiszernek. Tehát ilyen
táplálékkiegészítők a kutya se nagyon
vizsgálja őket. Tehát, hogy mindegy,
hogy mit ír a a gyártó rá. Ezért is én
soha nem szoktam javasolni, hogy hogy
ilyen
nem túl ismert márkákat válasszunk, mert
azok általában kevésbé minőségi
termékeket adnak, hanem inkább valami
nagyobb gyártótól, ami inkább
célkeresztben van. És akkor ott, hogyha
hogyha valami nem etikus dolog történik,
vagy problémák vannak, akkor az azokat
hamarabb észre szokták venni, mert
jobban
tehát, hogy mondjam, vizsgálják őket.
De m én úgy gondolom, hogy
természetesebb forrásból jó pótolni a
fehérjéket. Tehát a hús az egy csomó
olyan dolgot tartalmaz még pluszba, ami
a fehérje porban nincs meg. És az ételek
felszívódásához nagyon fontos a a food
matrix, tehát hogy az a ugye mi mi
aminossavakat akarunk bevinni, fehérje
komponenseket akarunk bevinni, és azt
szeretnénk, hogy azt a szervezetünk
asszimilálja, tehát hogy építse be,
csináljon belőle izmot, enzimeket,
csontozatot.
Ö de ehhez kell egy csomó minden, tehát
az izomgyártáshoz nem elég csak a
fehérje, hanem hanem kell például a vas
is, mertogy a a vörös öácsíkolt
izmok azok azoknak az a neve, hogy
mioglobin. Azért vörösek, mert hogy van
vas bennük, tehát hogy csak a fehérje
nem elég az izomszintézishez, tehát hogy
hogy kellenek egyéb dolgok is. És ezért
a hús, a vörös hús az egy jobb
alternatíva, és sok szempontból
egészségesebb és jobban telít és
>> természetesebb. Ez egyik, amit olvastam,
hogy azért használnak fehérreporokat az
emberek, mert a napi fehérje mennyiség,
amennyire szüksége van az embernek,
nagyon nehéz bevinni. Nagyon sok sok
ételt kell együnk ahhoz, hogy az a
mennyiségű fehérje be tudjuk hozni az
nagyon nagy mennyiségű ételt kell
megegyünk ahhoz, hogy azt a mennyiségű
fehérét be tudjuk vinni, amire
szükségünk van. Ezzel kapcsolatban
milyen meglátásod van?
Egy időben én is ajánlottam a fehérje
porokat, mert van egy egy ilyen
anabolikus abnaknak nevezett periódus,
ami általában
erőkifejtés, tehát hogy ilyen edzést
követő 48 akár 72 óra is lehet. Korábban
úgy tartották, hogy az első 25 perc egy
edzés után az nagyon fontos, hogy akkor
kell fehérje oldatot fogyasztani, mert
hogy az azonnal beépül az izmokba. De
manapság már vannak
ilyen kutatások, amik azt mondják, hogy
akár két napig is érvényes ez a hatás,
tehát két-három napig is. Ön úgy
gondolom, hogy régen se fogyasztottak az
eleink fehérje porokat, és hogy az
átlagember, aki most nem tehát, hogy nem
versenyre készül, merthogy kulturista,
és hogy akkor ott tényleg komoly
izomzatra kell szertegyen, szerintem
természetes forrásokból jó pótolni
ezeket a tehát a fehérjét, tehát hogy
kis magasabb hús és tojás fogyasztása
meg tejtermékek fogyasztása v egyébként
tejtermékekből viszonylag
gyorsabban lehet pótolni a a fehérje
mennyiséget. Folyékony tegytermékekre
értem, kefir szána jaurt, merthogy
azokban is ugye ezek a tej, tehát a
tejsavó fehérje meg a kazein található
meg benne. Mondjuk itt azt is meg kell
jegyezni, hogy a kazein az egyik
legnehezebben emészthető fehérje. Nem is
tudjuk 100%-ban megemészteni, mert ilyen
ilyen kis gömbökbe áll össze a
gyomorban. Tehát pont úgy kicsapódik,
mint amikor sajtot készítünk és savat
csepegtetünk a tejbe és akkor
kicsapódnak a tejfehér, és abból gyúrjuk
aztán össze a sajtot. Ugyanez történik a
gyomorban is, tehát savas közegben
érkezik a tej, és akkor kicsapódik a
tejfehérje.
De ettől függetlenül valamennyit azért
tudunk hasznosítani belőle. Csak például
a fehérje porokkasa a tejfogyasztással
is az a probléma, hogy hogy nagyon sokan
érzékenyek a tejfehérjékre. Tehát mégis
egy teljesen más állatfajnak a tejét
fogyasztjuk,
amire reagálhat a szervezetünk, és
sokaknál reagál. Ühüm.
>> És ezért a tisztítottsavó fehérje is,
ami kevésbé problémás, előfordulhat,
hogy hogy ilyen esetekben
én nem tudom javasolni, tehát nem fog
jót tenni az illetőnek.
>> Üm
jó, térjünk akkor az utolsó pontjára a
Jessek. Ő azt javasolta, hogy figyeljünk
a az időzítésére az étkezéseinknek.
És emlékszem, hogy ezt Józsa Levi
podcastjében is hasonlóan kiemelted,
hogy azt javaslod, hogy ha tehetik az
emberek, akkor inkább a vacsorát
halasszák el, és inkább a inkább
reggelizzenek.
És van ez az időszakos böjt is, amiről
esetleg egy kicsit beszélgethetnénk.
Jessie lényegében azt javasolt, hogy
akármelyiket is válasszuk, vagy a
reggelit, vagy a a csorát. Ő is amúgy a
reggeli mellett van zárójelbe, de de
akármelyiket halasszuk kell, ez legyen
rendszeres, ne össze-vissza étkezünk. Ez
miért fontos a a számunkra, hogy hogy
rendszeres legyen az étkezés?
Hát egyrészt azért, mert hozzá tudjuk
szoktatni a hormonrendszerünket, hogy
tehát hogy várja, tehát ilyen anticipált
étkezést, tehát hogy hogy várja azt a
azt a táplálékbevitelt, tehát rákészül
ugy a gyomossav termelés, mint az egyéb
hormon termelés arra, hogy most jön egy
nagyobb cukor, tehát szénhidrát, vagy
pedig zsírfehérje
adag.
És ez nagyon előnyös azoknál az
embereknél, akiknél valamilyen oknál
fogva de csökken az
emisztőenzimtermelés.
Tehát ez nagyon szépen vissza lehet
szoktatni a a szervezetet arra, hogy
megfelelő mennyiséggyomorossavot vagy
egyéb emésztőenzimet termeljen. A másik
dolog az, hogy étkezések között, hogyha
tartunk egy kis szünetet, akkor beindul
a béltisztulás, ami hát ugye nagyban
meghatározza a bélbaktérium összetételt
is. És a bélbaktériumaink ki, tehát
kihatással vannak a vércukorszintekre,
az emésztésre, a lelki állapotunkra.
említetted korábban a depressziót?
Tehát, hogy inkább vagyunk baktériumok,
mint ember, tehát hogy egy nagyon sok
funkciót
ellátnak, illetve befolyásolnak a
testünkben. És ahhoz, hogy hogy a
baktériumokat egy kicsikét ritkítsuk a
beleinkben, ahhoz az kell, hogy az
étkezések között hagyjunk szünetet, mert
olyankor indulnak be a béltisztuló
folyamatok, amik lelökkik
[Zene]
a bélnyáknak egy részét. ebbe laknak a
baktériumok, tehát ezzel együtt a
baktériumot is, tehát úgy úgy picikét
meg
megnyirválják ott a lakosságot. Másik
dolog az, hogy enyhe kalória deficitet
érünk el ezzel, tehát csökkentjük a napi
kalóriabbevitelt. Ha este marad el a
vacsora, akkor ez egy kicsikét
könnyebben elviselhető, merthogy
általában a tehát este le szoktunk
feküdni, alszunk, olyankor kevésbé
szenvedünk az éhség miatt.
Úgy általában este beindul az
energiafelhasználás, tehát a
kalóriaégetés a testben, amit fel lehet
erősíteni ezzel, hogy a vacsorát
hagyjuk-e. Erről már a a másik
podcastben kicsit bővebben szó volt,
tehát hogy hogy sok szempontból előnyös
az, hogyha egy étkezést kihagyunk a az
étrendből. Tehát régebb sem volt túl
gyakori az étkezés. Tehát egész
egyszerűen
a a az ősidőkben nem volt olyan magától
értetődő, hogy mindig volt, amit együnk,
és hogy ha jól akarjuk csinálni a
dolgokat, ahogy akkor valahogy efele
kellene visszamenni, mert hogy még
egyszer mondom, tehát a a bőség az nem
olyan régóta normális a számunkra, tehát
hogy egy olyan 200 éve nagyjából amióta
ennyire magától értetődő, hogy mindig
van táplálék, de hogy még eljöhet egy
olyan időszak, amikor nem lesz. És hát
én ilyen prepermentalitással
rendelkezek, de hogy hogy nem biztos,
hogy hogy a jelenlegi kényelmi szintünk
az mindig meglesz, és általában nem árt,
hogyha egy kicsikét edzük a testünket
rosszabb időkre, tehát felkészülni
mindig jobb.
>> Hát hogyha az emberiség történelmét
nézzük, akkor inkább éhezett az ember,
mint mint ez a bőség. Tehát hogyha most
az év milliókat nézzük, ez a 200 év, ami
az iparosodás után jött, ez a bőség, ez
ez inkább a a kivétel, és és nem ehhez
vagyunk szokva. De tényleg ilyen
szempontból, hogy ha egy vadász éles
kell legyen és fókuszált ahhoz, hogy
leterítse azt a mamus mamutot, akkor az
éhség az valójában pont, hogy élesebbé
kell őt tegye, nem pedig tompává. Tehát
nem az történik, hogy ilyenkor
erőtlenekké válunk, hanem pont, hogy
valami történik a testünkben. Ugye ez a
ketúzis.
és és a ketonokkal jobban funkcionálunk.
Jól van. Hát én én nagyon örvendek, hogy
végigmentünk így, ahogy így az az
igazság, hogy amikor először elolvastam
ezt a könyvet, akkor egy ilyen egy ilyen
hihetetlen öröm volt bennem, hogy vow
milyen egyszerű nyelvezettel, milyen
egyszerű tanácsokat adott ez a Jessy,
amit tarthatok is, kipróbáltam és
tényleg működnek is, és legalábbis az én
testemen működnek. pozitív irányba tolta
el a mert mert valójában a ketó az nem
fenn nem volt fenntartható számomra.
Viszont hasonló érzetet
kölcsönzött nekem, mint a mint amikor
mint amit a ketó alatt tapasztaltam.
Úgyhogy ennek nagyon hálás voltam, de
azért éreztem, hogy szükséges leülni,
mert így ahogy beszélgettünk, körülbelül
az volt az érzésem, hogy nagyjából
egyetértesz, de azért nem ilyen
egyszerűek a dolgok. Tehát azért
egyrészt nagyon sok részlet van, amit
amiről érdemes tudni. És mindenkire nem
fognak ezek működni mindenkinél, de
azért nagyjából fontos, hogy hogy
figyeljünk arra, hogy zöldségeket
együnk. Figyeljünk arra, hogy tanuljunk
meg otthon főzni. Figyeljünk arra, hogy
egyrészt az ételeknek a sorrendje
fontos. Ne együnk
olcsó szénhidrátokat magára. Tanuljunk
meg mozogni rendszeresen, legalábbis
étren. Te te azt javasoltad, hogy ne
feltétlenül utána, hanem előtte, hogyha
lehetséges. Kerüljük a hiperprocesszált
ételeket, kezdjük sós reggelivel. Ezek
voltak például a javaslatai, vagy pedig
erre a hogy rendszeresen étkezzünk, és
ugyanakkor étkezzünk, amikor
a a a lehetőleg, mert a testünk már
felkészül előre az étkezésekre.
Az az igazság, hogy én is ahhoz a
réteghez tartozok, akiknek ezek új
dolgok voltak. És azt hiszem, hogy ezért
is akartam ezt a podcastet mindenképpen,
ezt az epizódot megszervezni veled, mert
azt hiszem, hogy a hallgatóságom nagy
része pont ennyire kezdő, mint én.
Úgyhogy ennek nagyon örvendek, hogy itt
voltál, és arra gondoltam, hogy a hogy
csináljuk azt, hogy a kommentelők
között, akik a YouTube-on fognak majd
kommentálni, sorsoljuk ki ezt a a
glükózmitort. És arra gondoltam, hogy
írjátok meg a ti tapasztalataitokat
ezzel kapcsolatban, hogy ha elkezditek
ezeket a gyakorlatokat, például igen, az
ecet, hogy hogy kezdjétek el ezt a 10
praktikát bizonyos szempontból élni, és
írjátok meg a véleményeteket ezzel
kapcsolatban. Ez nekem működött, ez
nekem nem működött. Valójában egy ilyen
kis közösségként egymástól is fogunk
tudni tanulni, hogy lássuk, milyen
visszajelzések lesznek, és valaki közül
a a kommentelők közül között majd ki
fogjuk sorsolni ezt a glükózmonitort.
Kincső, nagyon köszönöm, hogy itt
voltál. Valamit még esetleg tennél
hozzá? Valami, ami esetleg kimaradhatott
és szívesen beszélnél róla? Nekem itt
még van pár kérdésem, amit most nem
tudok feltenni, de valami, amit úgy
érzed, hogy enélkül nem lenne elég kerek
ez a beszélgetés.
>> A ketogén diétánál kérdezted, hogy kinek
nem ajánlott ez a diéta? És én itt itt
muszáj kihangsúlyozzak egy saját nagyon
kellemetlen tapasztalatot.
Tehát terheseknek, szoptató anyáknak,
kisgyerekeknek nem szabad ketogén diétát
követni. Én én megtapasztaltam, hogy
milyen a milyen a ketoacidózis, tehát a
laktációs ketoacidózis KT10-ben is az
első alkalommal önhibámból, mert
megszületett a negyedik
kisgyermekem, a kislányom, és hát ugye,
mint minden hiú nő, hát én is szerettem
volna azonnal bomba formába kerülni, és
hát igyekeztem csökkenteni a
szénhidrátot, de hogy az nem volt elég,
és hát akkor nagyon enyhe tünet heteén
voltak, mert csak ájulás érzetem volt,
de az nagyon kellemetlen volt. Tehát
tényleg alig értem el az asztalig, hogy
valami cukrot kapjak. Aztán ahogy
sikerült egy cukoroldatot lerőltessek a
torkomon, azonnal oldódott is ez a
kellemetlen állapot. A másik már sokkal
durvább volt. Az
nemrégiben történt.
Azt kell tudni, hogy a kislányom az most
már három évet töltött, de még mindig
fennáll nálam a laktáció. kicsi
mértékben nem lehet tudni, hogy miért,
mert minden szempontból kivizsgáltuk.
Valószínű, hogy h hogy stresszalapon
>> mi az laktáció?
>> Tehát, hogy tejtermelés, tehát hogy még
mindig van tejtermelés.
Tehát azt kell tudni, hogy a prolaktin
az nemcsak a a tejtermelésért felelős
hormon, hanem immun szerepet is betölt a
testben. És mivel nekem van egy krónikus
bélgyulladásom,
amit most egyéb ilyen
stresszes komponensek, tehát magánéleti
problémák felerősítettek, ez valószínű,
hogy fokozta vagy fenntartja ezt a
tejtermelést. Lényeg az, hogy hogy
szoptatás alatt megnő a szervezetnek az
energiaigénye. Sokkal több cukorra van
szüksége, mint úgy általában. És én
elvállaltam egy időben a az asszisztens
asszisztenseknek a belgyógyászati
képzését, és ez azzal járt, hogy elég,
tehát este későn írtem haza, és egész
nap nem ettem semmit, vagy bekaptam a a
tepertőmet, ami ugye szénhidrátot nem
tartalmaz, csak zsiradékot. Tehát, hogy
ilyen egy ilyen koplalás plusz
ketózisban voltam, plusz volt ez a
tejtermelés, és ez a hármas kombináció,
ez nagyon rossz. És arra lettem
figyelmes, hogy ilyen őztartásban
merevedtek a kezeim, a lábaim. Nagyon
erős hasi görcsöm és hányingerem volt
egyébként a ketuaidózisnak ezek a
tipikus tünetei.
Hiperventiláltam, tehát hogy nagyon
gyorsan szuszogtam, gyorsan vert a
szívem, le voltam izzadva, nagyon
rosszul éreztem magam, tehát konkrétan
azt éreztem, hogy én meg fogok halni.
Ez kaptam intravénás cukoroldatot, meg
is oldódót, de hogy érdekes módon nem
állt helyre egyből a cukorháztartásom
éjszaka, megint rosszul lettem, kimentem
a konyhába és konkrétan összeestem.
Tehát arra ébredtem, hogy akartam inni
egy pohárcukros vizet. A pohár az össze
volt törve, cserepek körbe, karikába,
mindenhol. Én meg a földön fekszem,
tehát hogy nem egy veszélytelen dolog.
és hogy erre oda kell figyelni.
Tehát ennek a a lakosságnak nem szabad
ilyen ilyen diétákkal kísérletezni. Meg
kell várni, hogy járjon le a szoptatás,
és azután kell neki fogni ilyen
extrémebb diétás kísérleteknek. Tehát
addig a Jesséle javaslatokat lehet
csinálni. Azzal lehet mérsékelni a
hízást, mert nem mindenki fogy a
szoptatás alatt, van aki hízik, pont
hogy a prolaktin miatt.
De hogyha ez az időszak lejárt, akkor
akkor lehet egy kicsikét ezt
intenzifikálni, tehát hogy több mindent
ki lehet venni az étrendből, de addig el
nem jó, nem jó ilyen ilyen nagyon
szélsőséges étrendet folytatni.
>> Köszönöm nagyon szépen, hogy itt voltál
és tudtunk erről a könyvről beszélgetni.
Remélem még le fogunk tudni jönni
beszélgetni. Köszönöm.
>> Én is köszönöm.
>> Ha tetszett ez a műsor, akkor iratkozz
fel kérlek a csatornánkra. Ezzel tudsz
támogatni minket. Köszönjük a Week kávé
közösségnek a jó kávéért, az ötvös
udvarnak a helyért, valamint a
bizalomtőkének a támogatásért.
Nélkületek nem jöhetett volna ez létre.